I need to save so much money that I
don't have to work a job I hate work is
not fun I don't like working so if I
don't like working what am I going to do
for the rest of my life I just got laid
off I feel like there's a lot of people
in this situation what if we put
together a conference where a bunch of
laid off people could all share ideas so
I ended up saying well I'm not going to
get a job so I might as well see what
happens I got the chance to go do
Venture Capital which I think was the
most fascinating job ever I just get to
go see what people are building listen
understand invest in things that I
believed in and and watch them evolve
and grow and that was amazing so I think
my Outlook on money is I don't want to
spend it if I can avoid it but I do want
to have great experiences I think that's
like the whole theme of my life is
trying to find ways to upgrade your life
your money your travel everything while
spending less and saving
more this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge Trader who's
gone on the platform and has created a p
of Investments having done a bunch of
research and stuff and that Pi might be
like I don't know 20% Apple 20% Tesla
10% this 10% that but it generally way
more complicated than that and you can
see the performance of that particular
pie of stocks and shares and funds and
then if you want to copy that pie into
your own account you can just copy and
paste it directly in and then you can
invest any amount of money and it will
automatically split it according to the
allocation in the P so if you wanted to
just play around with £100 and you were
like okay that Pi looks good it will
split out that1 based on on the
allocations of the pi which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of £100 so it's literally free
money so you might as well so thank you
so much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode this episode is very excitingly
brought to you by hu I've been a paying
customer of hu since 2017 since my 5ifth
year of medical school and it's
absolutely fantastic for those occasions
when you need a meal but you don't have
the time to necessarily cook for
yourself now these are some of my
favorite product that he offers this is
the ready to drink which is a meal in a
bottle and each meal is 400 calories
with 22 g of protein which is pretty
reasonable and each serving has 26
vitamins and minerals as well heal ready
to drink is made from natural natural
ingredients like tapioca sunflower seed
coconut pee protein flax seed and hemp
seed protein it is 100% vegan like all
hu meals and it's gluten-free and
lactose free with no animal products and
no GMOs and heu ready to drink comes in
eight different flavors including
strawberries and cream and iced coffee
caramel along with the classics like
chocolate and vanilla now these are
widely available in supermarkets and
Corner shops and petrol stations all
around the UK but the best way to get
them is online and so if you're like me
and you have a fairly busy life where
you don't necessarily have time to cook
or make the time to cook then you might
like to try out h ready to drink also if
you haven't yet heard the episode of
Deep dive with the founder of heel
Julian Hearn you might like to check
that out but if you'd like to give heel
a try then head over to heel.com
deepdive and that link is available in
the video description and the show notes
as well and that link firstly helps me
out but it will also give you a free
t-shirt and a Shaker and so you can
check out heel ready to drink and you
can also check out the other products
that they offer so thank you so much
heel for sponsoring this episode this
episode is sponsored by kajabi and
they've actually got something really
valuable for all of our Deep dive
listeners now if you haven't heard of
kajabi it's basically a platform that
helps creators diversify their revenue
with courses and membership sites and
communities and podcasts and coaching
tools so it's one of the best places for
creators and entrepreneurs to build a
sustainable business we started using
kajabi earlier this year and as soon as
we started using it we were like oh my
God why haven't we been using this
product for the last 3 years it's got
everything you'd possibly need for
running an online course or hosting an
online community or building an online
coaching business and it essentially
makes it really easy to run your entire
online business from payments to
marketing tools to analytics kajabi has
everything that we creators need all in
one place and actually you don't
necessarily need a huge audience to
generate a sustainable income a Creator
on kajabi can for example make $100,000
by converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any any cut of what
you earn creators keep and own
everything the way kajabi makes money is
through the monthly subscription fee and
even though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion dollar to creators that
billion would be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through products on the platform now
back in May 2023 I did a keynote at a
kajabi in real life kajabi Heroes Event
in Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I used
to grm my business from Zer to over $2.5
million per year from course Revenue
alone now people paid for the pretty
expensive tickets to watch this keynote
at the kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode Chris thank you so much for
coming on this fun we're meeting in real
life for the first time cuz you're here
in London I know we talked about doing
this and I was like well I probably
won't make it to London and then I was
like hey I'm coming to London in London
and we're recording this at like 10 p.m.
so this is going to be super fun um I'd
love to get started with so you've got
this podcast all the hacks which I
discovered because you interviewed Tim
Ferris on Tim Ferris podcast about
growing a podcast and I listened to that
episode I was like hey that's really
cool that all the the tips about growing
a podcast but then I was like who the
hell is this guy like how did he
interview Tim FIS about growing a
podcast on Tim faris's podcast and then
you managed to randomly email me like
some weeks after I listened to that I
was like oh I know this guy and so
that's how we how we kind of kind of got
connected but I guess if we rewind the
clock like how did how did we get here
how did you come to be in this place
where you recording podcasts about hacks
and stuff and being friends with people
like Tim Ferris and how did we end up
just kind of talkinging I it's so
interesting my whole life I've I've
always kind of been that person that's
like ah maybe there's another way to do
this maybe there's another way to get a
deal uh I've always been a fan of
optimizing everything like in high
school I wanted to order I went to
boarding school and I really wanted to
like get pizza like everyone else did at
night everyone would order a pizza for
delivery but my parents didn't give me
like an unlimited budget in their credit
card so I would order pizza I would sell
seven slices and I would get one for
myself and I'd make a little profit if I
was hungry I'd sell six and eat two and
so you know I was kind of like trying to
find a way to get the experience that I
wanted without having to spend the money
and that was really like I had those
little things I never knew it was going
to be a real thing and then after
college I got a job in Investment
Banking not because I wanted to be an
investment banker but because I didn't
know what I wanted to do and everyone
said Investment Banking is the best job
and I was like well I don't have time to
figure out what I want to do so I'm
going to do the thing everyone told me
was the best job and I was like ah this
job is not for me it's not it's not the
kind of job that like entrepreneurs
enjoy um and so then I went to
management consulting which I thought
maybe better and it was kind of the same
thing and I was like gosh work is not
fun I don't like working so if I don't
like working what am I going to do for
the rest of my life well I need to save
as much money as possible like fire
financial Independence style Without
Really knowing what that was but it was
just like I need to save so much money
that I don't have to work a job I hate
and that took me down this path of okay
well I don't want to live a crappy life
so let's find a way to do everything I
want to do like let's go through okay I
like to travel okay I want to live okay
how do I house hack how do I do these
things just trying to find a way to make
that work eventually I found jobs I
liked but I was still so far down the
optimization train that it just became a
a thing I love doing damn okay cool um
okay so let's I want to I want to kind
of take take us back to back to the
beginning I guess so what did you study
in college and how did that lead you
into the investment banking route so I
went to Colorado State University not a
highly ranked University in the states
um and honestly I went because this girl
I was dating was going to go there and I
was like ah let's go there uh I thought
maybe I would have a better outcome
going to a worse school and standing out
than going to like a tier one school and
just being one of a bunch of people I
think that ended up being true but my
parents were not happy they were like
why why didn't you want to go to some
Ivy League school I was like ah this
seems great we broke up right away so uh
a little bit if I told you so but it
worked out and I was like well I want to
start a company I want to be an
entrepreneur I'm going to take a I'm
gonna get a business degree and then I
looked at the majors that we had and it
was like well it Finance marketing
management and there was one other I
can't remember and I was like well if I
run a company I'll probably hire someone
to do them and accounting I was like
I'll probably hire someone to do Finance
and Accounting uh marketing seems I
don't know I'll do marketing like I was
just I didn't know what to do I was like
management seems like a skill that you
kind of just either have or you don't I
didn't know what I was talking about so
I did marketing um and then I took a
bunch of other things like French and
you know entrepreneurship and math but I
went home over Thanksgiving which you
know it's like maybe 5 months before
graduation and all my friends who went
to these Ivy League schools had jobs and
I was like wait you have a job like my
school had not prepared anyone for a job
yet because most people weren't going to
the kinds of jobs you need to plan six
months in advance for so I was like what
are you guys doing and they're like oh
the best jobs invest in banking
management consulting and I just went
back to school and I went to the Dean's
office in the College of Business and I
went I said I need your help to get a
job in Investment Banking and management
consulting and somehow the dean of the
College of Business knew one guy that
worked at investment bank and one guy
that worked at management consulting
firm great gave me interviews um I
missed the deadline so one of them
offered me an internship and one of them
offered me a job nine months after
graduation so I took both and I thought
I have a backup plan so I did one didn't
like it did the other didn't like it
damn yeah so
it's I guess basically everyone I know
who did a non-medical degree went down
the either Investment Banking or
management consulting route and actually
a lot of people I know who do have
medical degrees are now trying to go
down those rout
like this is my exit strategy for medic
they medic forit they realiz they don't
like it and then they're see oh there's
a lot of money over there's a lot of
money with those people with their fancy
suits and and stuff um what was
Investment Banking like for you
Investment Banking imagine I I have no
idea what investment because I actually
don't really know what an investment
bank I didn't know what it was either so
like I was getting this job I was like I
got to go buy a book about what is what
is Investment Banking and um you know I
was like do I work at a bank so
basically you're supporting people like
at My Level like four tiers down from
the person actually doing the the job
I'm like making spreadsheets okay and
the whole idea was an investment Bank
works with companies and either helps
them go public or acquire companies or
get Acquired and kind of strategic uh
Financial transactions like that so my
job was like let's go some company wants
to get acquired they want to or some
company someone wants to go buy a
company in a space and they're like what
should we pay for this company let's go
look at all the private transactions
that have happened to in the space and
let's try to get an idea of what the
valuations were relative to their
revenues or relative to their profit and
what are all the public companies in the
space valued at on these metrics let's
come up with an idea of what's a fair
price at the end of the day you're
really just trying to come up with a way
to justify the price that you agreed on
because it's a negotiation so it seemed
like a little bit of show but sometimes
it's literally like we actually need to
do the show to send to our shareholders
so that we show that we did diligence
yeah um but at my level it was like hey
I'm going to go home why don't you make
this spreadsheet till 4:00 in the
morning I'll be back at 8:00 tomorrow I
hope you're back and I remember a week
went by where I went home and my
girlfriend at the time was asleep and I
left before she woke up and I was like
this is horrible like I don't I've not
even seen the person I live with awake
um and I was like I think I got to take
this other job which was a Manor
consulting job um which wasn't that
different except you're you're making
PowerPoint slides rather than Che yeah
okay so so you were in investment
banking for a few months before
realizing that it wasn't for you yeah
was so I did the internship at the end
of The Internship they offered me the
full-time job and I was like okay I'll
take the full-time job uh because I was
like I need to pay rent so I took the
full-time job up until this management
consulting thing started and I was like
Hey I've actually I'm I'm going to leave
I'm going to take this other thing and
they were kind of like okay like they
weren't upset I kind of was in this
weird spot where they didn't offer me
like they kind of said stay on as a
full-time intern instead of here's a
full-time offer where you're going to
get a bonus and you're going to get all
this stuff they were kind of like well
we want to keep you so soon as there's
an opening we'll give you a real job
until then you can be a full-time intern
we're going to pay you a little bit more
but it wasn't clear that I had a
full-time job it was kind of a weird
spot and so when the consulting job was
ready to start I was like thank you this
is a great experience I learned a lot
let's see what that's like nice okay so
we you've done your stint in in
Investment Banking um did that teach you
anything other than the fact that you
didn't like Investment Banking I mean I
think you just learn how to grind
through anything you know I I think
there are some jobs where especially now
I meet people are like oh you know I'm
just kind of cruising having fun I'm
living in a van like this was you were
working sometimes 22 hours in a day uh
and you just have to like grind through
things and you're working with very very
smart people even just the interview
process like if I never even took the
jobs having to go through these
interview processes where they're asking
you to do these complicated case studies
and like one time it was with a team and
so I was interviewing with other people
who were interviewing together working
on a project and then asked to give
feedback on the people I was
interviewing with so I think I just
learned a lot being surrounded by really
smart people and that was fun but at the
end of the day I think the problem I had
with both of those jobs was that it was
very hierarchical it was like there was
a moment in management consulting where
we were trying to close a deal as a firm
with a you know like a Fortune 500
company and I obviously wasn't the one
selling the deal that was like the
managing director and I was this
low-level you know first year
but a friend of mine happened to have
the CEO of that company was his stepmom
and I was going to hang out at his
birthday party and she was there and I
remember asking the managing director I
was like hey I'm actually going to go to
the CEO of this company that we want to
win business from I'm going to be at her
house this weekend do you want me to
talk to her about this and he's like no
that's not your job and I'm like I know
that's not my job but it seems like
there probably could at least be a
conversation worth having here and it
was like no that's not your job and I
was just like it feels and maybe I was
too full of myself but it felt a little
irresponsible for the company to not
entertain whether it was a good idea um
so it just didn't seem right and then at
the end of the day everything in my kind
of Life trajectory changed when I went
to this event called startup weekend
which was a guy in Boulder started this
thing where you got a bunch of people
together Engineers designers product
people just business people for a
weekend and you all broke into groups
and built companies and I drove up to
Boston from New York City and we built
this company it was silly it was called
desk happy it was was a Windows app that
every like some random number of time
like 45 to 90 minutes it would pop up a
thing and it would give you an exercise
like a five- minute exercise like
stretch or you know you know that thing
where like the Apple watch will buzz and
tell you to do something it was that for
Windows but like a decade ago and I was
like oh my God we built a company in a
weekend nobody downloaded the app like
it never went anywhere but I was like I
want to do this like this is amazing and
everyone's like well you should probably
live in San Francisco like everyone in
San Francisco is building tech companies
and I was like I will do that so I
immediately put in a request I said hey
could I move to San Francisco I'd really
like to work in the San Francisco office
they said sure I was like wow that was
so easy and then like a week into
working in San Francisco I got this call
to go to a meeting with a guy I'd never
met and I was like wow this senior
person wants to meet with me this is
cool and he was like you're fired oh
this was the management consulting thing
yeah yeah so it was 2008 middle of the
financial crisis I had thought you know
they kind of were like oh you're this
person that just transferred offices
you've got nothing on your plate you're
a great person to let go so so I was
fortunately uh show you know given an
opportunity to go do something else
which I think at the time I was kind of
disappointed but in the long run I think
it it was a huge impact because it
forced me to go find something else to
do damn okay so at this point it's 2008
you're probably like mid-20s how old are
you at this point 2008 I'm like 24 24
okay and 26 You' just moved to San
Francisco where presumably rents are
quite high and you you've just been
fired from your job like how does how
does that feel at that time yeah I'm not
good at math because it was actually 22
oh wow okay um no no it really sucked uh
I got laid off in November so I was like
oh man the holidays around the corner no
one's going to hire anyone in the US
between Thanksgiving and Christmas at
the end of the year so I was like what
am I going to do and so I actually had
no idea what I was going to do
fortunately um my girlfriend who's now
my wife had a job so we were like okay
great she had flown out to San Francisco
a month early found a job and maybe two
weeks before I got laid off she got a
job so I like we at least know how to
pay the rent and I really didn't have a
clue CL what to do except that I had
gone to this weird event called bar Camp
which is kind of like this Tech
conference but it's not really about
tech it's kind of about life and it was
an unconference where people just threw
up ideas of what they wanted to talk
about and it was you know it was just
like a fun place to be and I was like
this is really interesting I just got
laid off I feel like there's a lot of
people in this situation what if we put
together a conference where a bunch of
laid-off people could all share ideas
and you could bring entrepreneurs you
could bring Freelancers people could
learn skills like maybe I have a skill I
could freelance maybe someone wants to
start a company and I could do that with
them so I ended up saying well I'm not
gonna get a job so I might as well see
what happens and so I made this thing
called laid off Camp and I can't even
remember where I posted it I like posted
it on somewhere on the internet nobody
really found out about it at all but it
was just in the Zeitgeist enough that
TechCrunch wrote an article about it oh
wow okay and at the time I thought it
was fake because this woman emailed me
and she was like I'd love to write a
story about this I found it somewhere um
I work at Tech Crunch and I was like oh
this I was I felt like I was on top of
the world I called a friend of mine I
was like I just did this interview with
tech Crunch and he was like who was the
inter reporter and I told him her name
he's like I work with tech crunch a lot
I don't think that person works there
and I was like oh it turns out the woman
who wrote the I was the first article
she'd ever written at Tech crunch so she
nobody actually knew she really worked
there but that kind of you know caught
Silicon Valley kind of central Zeitgeist
around the recession at the time uh you
know got picked up in the San Francisco
Chronicle and by the time we did the
first event in San Francisco we had NPR
there we had the Wall Street Journal
there we had the New York Times there
CNN and um you know was really like a
big thing I didn't make any money uh it
wasn't a for-profit Enterprise uh I open
sourced the whole thing on a Wiki and
let people run 20 or so other laid-off
camps around the country but it was a
great opportunity to like test those
entrepreneurial muscles meet a bunch of
interesting people and kind of see what
a new world might look like for me so
what happened to late off C like what
did what was the yeah I mean I never I
never knew it was funny someone asked me
a few days ago they're like maybe you
should start this back up again you know
s pretty good um no nothing really
happened um it kind of fizzled out the
recession kind of stopped being a thing
people were talking about we done one in
almost every city in the country that
was a major metro area and I said okay I
need to find a job um I had met a couple
companies through this process that had
hired me to do random freelance things
one startup was like well you could
worked at Investment Bank maybe you can
help us build the models we need to go
raise a late stage round of financing
like great I'll do that I need I need
money um another company was like well
you put on these all these events we
want to start putting on events in the
community as part of our business
strategy will you help us throw events
great I'll do that um so I did a few
freelance jobs and I decided I wanted to
find a job at a company but before I do
all my freelance jobs are coming to an
end my wife hated her job um I think
still girlfriend at the time but really
hated her job it was pretty terrible she
was like I got to find something new and
I was like gosh well my freelance things
are over you hate your job maybe we
should take one trip and like we have a
little bit of savings not much we'll
take one trip and then after that we'll
hit it hard you'll find a new job I'll
find a new job we kind of have a better
sense of what we want one thing led to
another we rented out our place
furnished for more money than we were
paying in rent so we're actually making
money um because it looked it turns out
the Delta between like a furnished
apartment that you can rent for a month
or two and like apartment you have for a
year unfurnished is actually a margin
you know profit margin business
and we bought a one-way ticket with
points to South Africa and we just
backpacked for seven months um the goal
was to get from South Africa to
Singapore by land there were a few
borders we couldn't cross uh and we had
to fly but yeah that was not what we
intended like you know I was gung-ho
ready to work in Tech ready to get back
into it but it just seemed like an
opportunity we couldn't miss up and uh
we put this whole map on the wall we
like let's put pins on countries we
think would be cool to see and we're
like that's a lot of countries how are
we ever going going to you know the
average person takes a trip like I'm on
now you go to London and Paris for a
week and a half I was like how am I
going to see 40 countries around the
world if every year we can go to one or
two of them and then I'd read this book
vagabonding oh yeah good and uh Rolf
pots is awesome I got a chance to
interview him on my podcast and um I was
like oh maybe we could just do this
long-term travel thing and it's so much
cheaper because you're taking buses and
trains and couch surfing instead of you
know flights and staying in hotels and
so we did this whole trip
on like $7,000 for 7 months which you
know still seems crazy to me about
$1,000 a month about $30 a day and it
was like one of the most amazing
life-changing experiences and then I
submitted a talk to talk about all these
things at South by Southwest and it got
approved and they were like we want you
to come speak in March and I was like
well now I know when the trip ends so
you know in November or something we
booked a one-way ticket from Singapore
to Austin to go to South by Southwest
and you know that was the the transition
to the next chapter of my life oh so
much to talk about so um yeah ever since
I read vagabonding I think uh an episode
of the Tim F show probably turned me
onto it um and then started listening to
rol pot's podcast as well it was always
in my mind as a thing that it would be
really cool to do um but I was always in
this traditional job and so in 2020 when
I took a break from medicine I was like
right this is going to be my chance to
do my little vagabonding trip but then
pandemic and everything everything
closed and so I've not yet done my V
vagabonding trip uh but I'm trying to
talk my girlfriend into it at some point
where we'll do the traveling around the
world for a year somewhat aimlessly kind
of thing the sooner you do it the better
because what I've learned is my
standards have risen over time and you
know we stayed at a hotel in India that
I think was $1 a night I don't think
that I could like I don't I want to say
that I could go do it again but I feel
like I've gotten old enough we have two
kids like what I going to put my kids in
a room that like barely has running
water the windows are just holes in
concrete walls probably not so the the
younger you do it the sooner you do it
the more comfortable with the grit and
the grime Yeah the more you can take a
trip that I just think is a trip you
can't replicate like you can't replicate
staying in some $2 a night hostel down
an alley you know when you have a family
if if that's in the card Som yeah yeah
I've heard that this is very much a
thing that sort of you kind of are able
to do in your 20s and then not really
beyond that and it's almost like um I
think I was reading die with zero that
about this and and a few other things
they talk about
how it's not it's not just when you're
old and like you've got illnesses and
stuff or like families and stuff where
you can't take trips like that it's
actually just we when you don't want to
do that anymore cuz going around hostels
and stuff at the age of 19 is very
different to the age of 31 for example
yeah it's funny I interviewed Bill
Perkins who wrote die was zero and I
said you know do you have any regrets of
things that you didn't do and his one
was I didn't take a gap year I didn't go
explore when I was younger and now it's
just a different EXP experience I would
have that's not to say you know I I got
an email from one of my listeners who
has a family and they've been living
nomadically for years so it's not to say
you can't travel with kids you can't
travel with a family I just think
there's a certain type of travel where
you're like I don't know where I'm going
to go to tomorrow and I'm just going to
wander around till I found a place to
sleep and I remember doing that in
Zanzibar off the coast of Tanzania or I
guess it's in Tanzania and we were just
like for 3 hours we were trying to find
a place to stay because we didn't have a
plan and we went to to a like if things
were fully booked finally we found
something but you just can't do that
with kids like you can't like it just
maybe at some age but our kids are you
know two under three and like it's just
not going to work so there are some
elements of a trip that you you could do
at any age but there are some that I
would highly advise you to do if you
before you start a family if that's
something you want to do often on on
hearing that kind of advice some people
would be like oh but what about the Gap
in the resume what about like the the
dot dot dot how how would you approach
that kind of fear it's funny I I applied
for a job once and the guy that reviewed
my resume was like you've changed jobs
too much um and I was trying to explain
I was like well no actually I had this
Investment Banking internship and like
it wasn't supposed to be forever and
then I did this management consulant and
then I got laid off it wasn't my fault
like it's not like I'm a flaky person
it's just I had these series of things
and he was kind of very rigid in the way
he thought about it and I was like well
I guess my answer to you would be that
person is probably going to wonder
what's happening I think for every one
person like that there's probably 25 or
30 people who are going to be impressed
that you took that trip want to know
what it taught you uh you know jealous
that they didn't take it themselves and
so I don't think there are very many
people who would look at a year off and
not and and judge you or hold you
against getting a job because of it so I
don't know I would tell someone that
obviously you might spend money and be
broke that's like an important thing so
make sure you have the savings to do it
or uh you know go on one of those trips
or you work on a farm you know there's
lots of ways to do it
but I wouldn't let taking a year off and
and the impact it would have on your
resume stop you from doing it and I
don't think very many people who've
lived long enough to reflect on that or
our older would say that in fact I don't
think I've made a resume for a while
right like I don't know if you have a
resume that's current like I have a
LinkedIn page which kind of is enough
yeah a lot of people say that when they
do a a sort of extended travel thing
that it changes them it teaches them a
lot um having done one of these trips I
almost can't imagine what what it would
be like so like I guess what what did
you learn on that trip how did it how
did it change your outlook how did it
change your life I think there were a
few small things that happened that that
maybe had big impacts but I I didn't
have one of these like eat prey love
moments where I was like I left and I
was a changed human and all these you
know you kind of got to the end and
you're like oh okay like there wasn't
that moment for me but there were a few
things that I think were important one
was when you travel especially when you
travel outside of if you know if you
live in the states and you come to
London it's not going to be as different
as if you go live in Southeast Asia or
you you know track through Africa or you
go to South America a place that's kind
of a very different way of living and I
think what I learned that was super
fascinating was that all around the
world people have found ways to be happy
and they found very very different ways
to be happy and I think the thing that
has led me down this like intense
optimization part of life is not
believing that any particular way of
doing something is just by default the
right way so there's a way that most
people do things and just because the
people you're surrounded with say oh you
know this is what you do you go to a job
and you don't take a year off well in
the UK I feel like almost everyone takes
a gap year after college but in the US
maybe that would be frowned upon because
most people don't do that um so I I
think the biggest lesson I took away was
there are people that do W have wildly
different days the structure of their
days the way they work the way their
family works the way their family lives
and it all just works for them so it
made me question maybe to a level that
many of my bosses managers uh friends
don't like it's like anything we do
could be there could be a better way to
do it so someone says oh let's do this
I'm like well is there a better
restaurant to go to is there a better
way to get there is there a better deal
to be found um I think that's one of my
biggest takeaways and
then I think from a material possession
standpoint I feel like there's an
inverse relationship between just
General happiness like the people who I
met that had the least seemed the most
content with life um and the people that
I met that had the most seemed the least
content with life uh and so not to say
that I don't have things and you know
I'm not a minimalist by any stretch of
it but it's just like it it's very easy
to be happy just running around in a
field and like kicking a soccer ball or
even like something that is a bag of a
bunch of trash bags bald together to
resemble a soccer ball so I don't know
those are two important lessons but I
didn't have a I knew what I I thought
I'd come back and be like I know what to
do with my life no nothing none of that
a brle pretty fun trip $30 a day like
trying to get from South Africa to
Singapore yes where where do you have to
fly like what were the borders that you
can so we couldn't get over the border
to Sudan oh yeah um and so that was a
tough one um Iraq Iran Afghanistan yeah
and uh Burma Myanmar was one where you
could go but you could only fly in and
so in each of those three areas we ended
up flying over um so we flew from India
to Thailand we flew from um like the
Middle East over to India and then we
flew over uh Sudan were you concerned
about your safety at any point during
this trip that's that's another thing
that often seems to come
up really I think there was like there
was like one point where I think we're
in the middle of a really busy Market in
the evening and I was trying to figure
out where to go and I had the map on a
PDF on my computer it was like this
cheap $200 like Mini Mini PC this Dell
computer and I remember opening up my
laptop my wife was like you probably
shouldn't just like open a laptop in the
middle of the street here so like maybe
that moment but there really wasn't a
moment where it was like wow we like I
feel you know very scared right now um
there are moments where like I don't
know what to do we get to a bus station
there's no bus and there's no place to
stay and it's like okay well let's go to
the only store that's open and ask
everyone that comes into the store if
they're driving this is Malaysia
so we just like are you going to qualm
nope are you going to qual andur and we
just kept asking until someone's like no
but like this other guy I know is let me
give you a ride to this semi-truck where
he's going there and then we just like
get in a semi Tru with some guy who says
he's going to qu andour and like you
know we're just like hanging out in his
car and he was listening to Britney
Spears but he didn't speak English so it
was like this amazing moment of someone
like singing to American music but not
really actually speaking English um
went through a border crossing and he
like closed the curtain in the little
area behind in the bed of the truck
where we were like hiding I like are we
being smuggled through so I would say we
were like that was maybe a moment where
we were like a little nervous but I
think by that point we'd already had
four months of just Serendipity making
things better they were like I don't
know we haven't hitchhiked a lot so like
this will be a great story let's give it
a go okay so I I definitely want to talk
more about the kids stuff and the
optimization stuff before we do that so
you finished your seven months of
traveling you're at South by Southwest
what did you talk about in in the talk
so the talk I submitted was like a fun I
think it was called like fun employment
and I invited a friend who'd never been
laid off to like co- do it with me as a
panel just because you know we were both
trying to optimize for getting a talk
and he was like well you're talk what
you could talk about is more in the
Zeitgeist and I was like well you work
at a company that's like a really hot
cool company right now so like the combo
of that surely will be approved as a
talk at South by um and sure enough it
was that South by was really interesting
because it was this weird opportunity to
just go meet all these people in this
industry that I wanted to get into so
the talk was rather I it was like what
does it mean to be unemployed what how
can you make the most of it it was kind
of one of these if you're trying to
understand the world of getting laid off
and figuring out what to do with it come
to this talk so I wouldn't say the talk
was any like if there was a recording of
it I would not recommend you go watch it
um but that entire experience of like
immersing yourself in a new community of
people and trying to figure out what you
want to do in that Community was like a
very profound moment in my career um and
it was back when South by Southwest was
a small conference that not a lot of
tech people went to um and over the next
10 years it kind of totally went the
other end when it like to deal because
the only context in which I've heard
about it is a 4-Hour Work Week launch
thingy and listening to the audio of
that like a few months ago and thinking
wow that was actually a really good talk
from back in 2007 or or whenever it was
and also I think it it got canceled in
Co like that's literally the only two
data points I have about it so what is
South by South twist what was it when I
first went it was like primarily a music
festival it was like a twoe music
festival then they I think they added
film and then they added this like
emerging interactive component so it was
very much known when you first went to
South by I was like oh I'm going to
South by South was like oh you must love
music I was like actually I don't really
like live music and people were confused
um but it was this like the internet
conference um and you know all the early
kind of Internet tech people were there
companies like dig were throwing big
parties um I remember spending a lot of
time in the early days with like Gary
Vayner Chuck who was like running around
like throwing events um so it was kind
of like that early web creatory World um
that hadn't really didn't really have
like an event and South by Southwest was
the event and I remember for probably
eight years it was like every year there
was not a thing that I a conference that
I missed other Southwest was like the
one conference that I wouldn't miss
because it was when all the people I
knew whether they lived in New York or
the Bay Area everyone would convene on
Austin and there'd be you know all the
events the parties everything it was
just a great place to meet all those
people and a lot of the fun stuff
happened in like you know people's hotel
rooms late at night where you're just
kind of jamming on random ideas and um
the number of companies that came out of
those Jam sessions of people that were
just like I have an idea everyone's like
w what's this person really doing and
it's like oh that was Travis kalanick
who went on to start Uber and like all
this crazy stuff out of these rooms but
yeah it was uh you know I just it was
like a very right place time kind of
moment for me where I just kind of like
entered this industry of tech in Silicon
Valley and met a lot of interesting
people and I was like this is going to
be my career for the next
decade how important do you think that
is these days like the whole finding a
community finding a a senius as Austin
Cleon talks about is that something that
you've seen like sort of beyond that
point has this been helpful for you or
for other people that you know I think
the network of people that I got to know
and built in the you know let's call it
like broadly speaking like the internet
you know entrepreneur software creation
Community like Silicon Valley but like
extended to the country startup world
was like the most valuable thing towards
any of the path that I took so it was
like when I wanted to get a job um you
know it was being able to have people
who I'd met who'd gotten to know me and
my personality and seen that I did this
crazy thing with laid off Camp like oh
you should take a bet on this kid he's
got a lot of like audacity to go start
random stuff um that community of people
was what made all these things possible
and even today when I'm now in a
different world a Creator World a lot of
those early relationships uh you know
are still really important there's a a
different but kind of overlapping
Circles of like startup entrepreneurship
investors and creators and I think we've
kind of we're in like a WhatsApp group
that merges those two really well but I
don't know I'd say it's the most
valuable thing that I ever did was go to
South by Southwest and start to build a
community of people now had you done
that 10 years later I think it would
have been hard because at that point
there were every brand was there
sponsoring things and it was probably
hard to find your community so I would
say when new emerging things are
happening new events New conferences
like that's a really great opportunity
versus you know like CES now is like
probably not the best place there's
certainly good events and you can
probably go meet interesting people but
you might have to go a little more niche
or a little more emergent of kind of
events to go find that or a little more
and by Niche I mean it could be category
it could be like I really want to get
involved in fintech so I might go to you
know a conference there or it could be
like I'm going to focus on people in the
Bay Area or people in London or people
in New York rather than trying to go to
like the big thing um but yeah I would
say find people anywhere they are and
build that Community yeah yeah I think
about this a lot whenever um you know
these days it's it's nice cuz I get
invited to go to conferences and I'm
going to charer in the UAE like tomorrow
to give a talk and stuff and before
going to one of these things I'm always
a bit like oh you it's a long way to
travel and like woes me etc etc and then
I get there and I meet the people who
are there and I'm like okay cool this
was 100% worth it this is super super
fun um and just the I think the
Serendipity that you unlock by actually
going to things where there are other
people doing a thing like even you know
one one conversation I had with our
mutual friend Erica Colberg like a week
ago in Dubai she and I had never met
before then we kind of talked on on
Instagram DMS a little bit but that
conversation might be the most Roi
positive conversation I've had this year
in terms of the a decision we're going
to make for the business and it's was
just always I found a lot of times in my
life connecting the dots looking
backwards is always from has been from a
moment of a serendipitous interaction
that I could not have predicted at some
sort of event where I put the effort
into going to the thing rather than like
oh I'll just sit in the hotel room I'll
just like I'll just do some work and I
always find that the the expected value
of actually putting yourself out there
is stupidly High yeah the worst part is
it's not always high but like it's it's
um you know the CEO of wealth front a
guy named Andy rackliffe always talked
about when you're Building Products he's
like I care about the slugging average
not the batting average and for the
international folks this is a American
baseball reference which and I don't
even follow American baseball but the
general idea is it's like how often are
you hitting a home run and scoring
points versus how often are you hitting
the ball and so if I go to five events
conferences whatever it is I care less
that I meet five interesting people I
care that at one of them I had like you
a meaningful Contra conversation that
will change the trajectory of my
business my personal life or something
and it doesn't happen every time but I
would rather have four conferences where
every fourth Conference changes my life
or my business than have four
conferences and the other three do
nothing or than four conferences where
each one I meet an interesting person
I'm not saying I don't want to meet
interesting people hopefully I meet an
interesting person at all of them but
I'm going for those really really big
moments and they don't happen every time
and so it was funny when I was thinking
about you know do I go to business
school and I was like no no that's just
like management consulting uh Investment
Banking 2.0 but I was talking to someone
I was like I bet if you just bought a
business class ticket from New York to
San Francisco and you just flew back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
talked to the person sitting next you
you would probably unlock a similar
amount of value as if you spent the same
amount of money you know going to HBS M
I'm sure many people listening
especially the ones who went to HBS like
no no no like I totally disagree but the
idea being you will probably have six or
seven of those flights where nothing
happens and then every six or seven you
might have one really really powerful
interesting conversation that leads to
some crazy opportunity the hard part is
if you have the six or seven bad ones
first continuing to go for the next the
next one when it's not there and so I
have definitely been to conferences
where it was just totally not worth it
or have flown to a important meeting
that didn't pan out but I it's happened
enough times that it's like I I got to
keep trying and so I think it's a hard
thing especially if you're you know now
we have kids I'm like talking to my wife
I'm like okay I'm going to go to this
conference I really appreciate you
helping out extra so I could be out of
town and then I come home and I was like
you know what that was a waste of time I
shouldn't have gone but I promised that
like if I do this five times one of them
won't be a waste of time but it's really
hard when you have the waste of time
when the opportunity cost is high and
all that but I still encourage everyone
listening to go put themselves out there
a little bit more and try to find that
community and and look for those super
high Roi
interactions what do you think is the
balance
between put your head down and do the
work versus go to conferences and meet
people just to weave a um somewhat false
dichotomy between those two things I
mean it depends where where you are at
what stage in your life if you're
working a job and you're trying to
figure out how to transition somewhere
just doing the work is probably not
going to have that impact if you just
started a company and you're trying to
find product Market fit for the business
you started going to the conference
might be helpful to give you a new
perspective but like sometimes you just
need to do the work and so I don't think
there's a real answer I think I've
definitely had moments I remember a fun
moment where a friend of mine were
joking about how this one friend of ours
who started a company seemed like he was
way too down the conference path and so
we were like gosh this guy just needs to
like sit at his office and work and like
with his team for like two weeks
straight so we created this idea where
we found this person who is a professor
at some University who did a lot of
research in Antarctica we made up a fake
email address pretending to be them and
invited our friend from this email
address to come to an all expense paid
trip to South or to Antarctica for a
conference for Tech lead ERS so we went
back and forth we talked about how we
were comping all the flights we started
scheduling the flights for this person
we had it all like planned out um we
even like made up fake I think we said
like Jack dorsy is coming to this
conference and all this stuff and then
finally like maybe two weeks before we
were at this bar and we were like he was
you know I'm so excited I'm going to
Antarctica it's gonna be so cool and we
were like yeah and so we finally like
broke the news that we' made this thing
up but like but good news now you have
two uninterrupted weeks that you can get
work done and I don't think he
appreciated it like we thought he would
uh we haven't really caught up since
then um you know on this topic at least
but uh but yeah I do think you can go
too far down the path of like oh I'm
going to the next thing I'm going to the
next cool thing but it really depends
where you are at the stage of your
company
it's when I talked to other Founders and
CEOs when I was running one of my
businesses it was interesting how so
many of them were like I I need to spend
like half my week unscheduled just to fi
find the right thing to work on and and
I can't plan it so in that stage it's
like it's not just grinding it's like
leaving room to think and see what's
next what's the thing in your business
that you're missing what's the thing in
your career your life that you're not
you're overthinking so I think it's
important to do that but maybe time box
it be like okay there are two
conferences this year around those two
conferences I'm going to go I'm going to
leave a couple days after to process
everything great but don't be looking
every week for the next thing yeah nice
um in terms of optimizations hacks all
that kind of stuff any tips for
conference attendees let's say you're at
a conference it's like what do you do at
set conference to I guess make the most
of it yeah so here's one thing I do
which I don't know if this is crazy or
not but I always email the conference or
if some conferences just give you the
list of all the attendees great um most
of the times that list doesn't also
include the speakers so but the speakers
is always the one thing that's public
and so I try to combine those two lists
so that I have a list of everyone that's
going I try to figure out who and the
funny thing is I would say 50% of the
most impactful conversations I've had at
conferences or with people that I didn't
even know who they were I just randomly
met them but about 50% of them were with
a very targeted set of people that were
often speakers at the event or like you
know successful people who are attending
but maybe not speaking so I'll go
through the list one by one trying to
figure out who at this conference do I
want to interact with if they're giving
a talk I know they're probably going to
be in the room that they're giving the
talk and so before after that talk might
be a good time to run into them um but I
will actually go and pull like LinkedIn
photos or some photo of a person I'll
put them all in a notes dock on my
iPhone and like I'm in a room and I'm in
the corner I'll pull up my phone I'll be
like looking at all the faces just to
kind of like brush myself so when I'm
walking around the room I'm like looking
out for those people that I want to
engage with and try to find them so I'm
like you know it's kind I kind of feel
like I'm like a mercenary in the corner
I'm like okay I got to go find this this
person with brown long hair I'm like
walking around looking for them but I'm
very tactical about it trying to have
those conversations I usually only end
up hitting about you know 30 40% of the
people I wanted to find but I do hit 30
to 40% of them and I don't think I would
if I wasn't sitting in the corner of the
room every now and then roll running
through my list trying to be like oh
there's that person I want to go engage
with let's walk up I think walking up to
a random person is like one of the least
comfortable things that one can do and
so one person gave me this advice I did
an episode my podcast on kind of
networking at events um and asked asked
about this but one person was like just
practice it in low stakes environment go
to a bar where literally it doesn't
matter who you meet and just walk up to
random people and start conversations
it's probably easier than you think and
if you could do it in a low stakes
environment where it doesn't even matter
maybe when you're traveling you're never
even going to see these people again you
don't have any friends in common like if
you can really build that muscle of like
just walking up to someone and being
like hey what's going on um was one and
then leaving always being the person who
leaves first it's like everyone at this
conference especially if you're going to
these speakers they do not they probably
want to leave after a few minutes maybe
you're really exciting maybe you're
really engaging but um you know so so
it's kind of like a power move to be
like all right you know I'm sure you've
got lots of important stuff to do I I do
too I got to go not being the person
that just sits there talking to them
forever and trying to get them to commit
to some next thing in person it's so
much harder if you if you're a podcast
host you want someone to come on your
podcast don't be like hey can email
later about XYZ be like hey could you
like get them to soft commit in person
to whatever the next step is whether
it's grabbing a coffee making an
introduction or something it's so hard
to say no to things in person I know I
get this all the time usually we have
Gordon our videographer with us and he's
like Al you've said yes to too many
things you need to start giving Dan's
email my assistant rather than your own
and all this kind of stuff yeah so ask
people to do whatever you want in person
because people like Ali are are much
easier to get to committ it's hard
enough to say no VI email yeah and they
just know what they look like so you can
go find them yeah um any do you do you
talk to people on planes like I feel
like you you seem like the sort of guy
that would strike up conversation but I
don't know if you do anything
interesting like that like planes buses
coffee shops that kind of thing I
think less and less I think if I'm
flying by myself and I'm sitting next to
a person and it seems like maybe there's
something worth H having a conversation
about I'll say hi and but I wouldn't say
I'm like the person who's always
striking up the conversations on the
plane I think you know it's probably I
don't know if I were sitting next to a
random other person by myself not
traveling with my family I might end up
having a
conversation one in four times okay okay
no fair play but I'm not a four and four
like I've been I I was rereading this
book called The Luck Factor by Richard
wisman um he who's this like psychology
Professor who who I had on the Pod a few
months ago um and this is like one of
the like OG selfhelp books that was
really releas in like 2002 I first read
when I was like 16 years old and it
talks about the factors that um like
people who say that they're lucky versus
people who think that they're unlucky
like what are the different kind of
behaviors uh and one of the main ones is
the people who think who call themselves
lucky tend to be the sorts of people
that go to conferences and say hello to
people and will talk to random strangers
and coffee shops I was like damn I go to
conferences and I say hello but I don't
do the coffee shop thing so I'm kind of
glad that you don't either that makes me
feel probably it sounds like I might do
it a little more than you but um yeah I
just feel
like I'm a big proponent of saying yes
to random things if someone's like hey
do you want to come to the thing it's
like yeah let's just do it um but I
don't know I don't know if you have to
talk to the person in line like unless
there's a reason to I don't know if you
have to be that person to be lucky if
you will yeah yeah I think my heris for
for a lot of things is uh would I be
likely to regret doing this and usually
the answer is no and so I just kind of
do the thing even if it comes at the
expense of like for like for example
this podcast recording tonight where I'm
kind of recovering from the flu and I
was like oh I don't you know I should
probably just sleep early cuz I've got a
fly tomorrow I was like you know what am
I going to be likely to regret meeting
up with you in real life while you're
while we're in this in the same city for
the first time and God knows how long
probably not let's just let's just see
if we can make happen at like 10 p.m.
and I'm super glad we did and so it's
just things like that where often taking
a bit of a hit in terms of like sleep or
recovery and stuff I I do find to be
like I've I've so rarely regretted yeah
kind of staying up a little bit late to
do something that seems cool yeah I
think I feel the same way yeah this next
season of your life so we we talked
about the travel thing and then you went
to South South Southwest and you decided
all right cool I found my tribe what
happened in this next season of your
life so I decided I'm going to work at a
startup like this was the plan from
three years ago I was like I'm going to
move to San Francisco and we're going to
Startup and then I was like well I got
laid off I did freelance I traveled so I
basically went around and I was like
what I trying to figure out what the
hottest companies were and as a proxy
for that I was like who who's raising a
bunch of money you know what who's doing
interesting stuff the iPhone 3GS had
just come out had location and GPS and
there was a company that was started by
a bunch of X dig people and dig was like
a really hot internet company I was like
I'm going to go work at this company
simple Geo like I my tactic wasn't apply
to 10 jobs it was I'm going to work at
simple Geo that was it I didn't have a
plan B so I I didn't know anyone that
worked at simple Geo but I asked someone
I knew who knew one of their investors
if they could connect me with the
investor and I was just like look I am
so excited about this company and I made
this probably like 20 Page PowerPoint
presentation about why I was so excited
about the industry and the
looking back on it I was like I didn't
know anything like I was like it was
ridiculous but that didn't matter What
mattered was that some random kid was so
excited that they made a presentation
about their company like most people are
trying to hire convince people to work
for them and I was out there trying to
convince them how excited I was about
what they were building and I think they
saw that and I now know having been on
the other side of the situation like if
anyone does that kind of work you should
at least entertain a conversation of
whether you would hire them and so they
were like come on and you you can do
business development I was like great
what's that like I feel like the the
life the theme of my career is like
you're going to be a best maker great
what's that you're going to be man well
what's that um and so the idea was we
built this product but we didn't know
who to sell it to yeah so I was like can
you go meet people and see if you can
sell this thing we built and maybe kind
of tell the engineers who were building
it what they could change so that you
could sell
it that wasn't a successful Endeavor
like the company wasn't um it turns out
we had a really cool technical product
that this like the actual software we
built was really really fascinating but
there wasn't a really monetizable use
case for it and so the business didn't
work out but I think joining a company
that had a really great reputation that
was right in the middle of some kind of
theme emerging that was founded by a
bunch of notable people or at least
people who left a notable company meant
that even though that company went under
10 15 years later when I talk about
having worked there people like oh I
remember that company like it's still
stands out even though it failed um and
the network of people I met at that
company because it had attracted
similarly other really you know amazing
people um you know were people that I I
stay in touch with and I've worked with
since and so was all worth it even
though the whole thing uh you know only
lasted a year because the company kind
of didn't work out yeah but in that
process I met a few other people who
were like Hey we're starting this other
company do you want to come over here
and I was like great let's go do that um
and I was like what should I do here and
they're like well we don't really know
what you're going to do we just know
that we're not going to hire a person to
do really anything other than design and
Engineering so you're going to do all
the other things I was like great I'm
going to learn to be a product manager
and a researcher and a you know
accountant and like all the things um so
I kind of played that like go start
another company and that company ended
up lasting about a year before we got
acquired by Google so I went to Google
and um I interviewed a Google and at the
end of the interview they were like you
are a product manager and I was like
great that like I had no idea what that
was uh and so they send you to training
and they're like this is product manager
training I was like great now I know
what my job is uh and I worked at Google
for about three months as a product
manager and then we had this unique
opportunity to go to Google Ventures and
I I was like do you want to go be a
venture capitalist and invest in
startups professionally for three years
or continue down this product management
path and a small part of me thinks that
I might have had a a much more
interesting path if I had stayed but the
vast majority of me thinks of course I
made the right choice but I do think
there was something to be learned from
you know Google's an incredible product
building machine and had I stuck it out
and and learned in multiple different
areas of the company how to build
products the way Google does I think
that would have been a great learning
opportunity just not as great as seeing
what it's like to invest in I don't know
I think in my time at the fund we
invested in 150 or 200 different
startups took pitches from thousands so
that experience I think was far
outweighed it but I still wish that I
gotten to kind of peek behind the
product curtain at Google for a little
bit longer and I guess you enjoyed these
jobs unlike Investment Banking
management consulting that kind of thing
yeah I mean the product management one
was a bit weird because I landed at
Google+ which at the time uh that phras
in ages at the time Google Plus had
about a thousand people working on it
right which I think like the internal
funny joke was like they're at any given
point in time there are more people
building go+ than using it um at least
actively using it um so I think I didn't
love that that org was so big but it
probably didn't need to be anywhere near
that size that everyone was working on
some tiny insignificant thing but the
core product didn't even have product
Market fit so it's like can you work on
the notifications for a feature that no
one's using that's part of a bigger
feature in an app that no one's like it
felt
insignificant um but Google pays you
well so you're like well maybe I'll keep
doing this uh but fortunately for anyone
working on a product like that Google
eventually they realized that and
they're really good about letting you
move to other teams I got the chance to
go do Venture Capital which I think was
the most fascinating job ever which was
like I just get to go see what people
are building listen understand invest in
things that I believed in and watch them
kind of evolve and grow and that was
amazing and lasted about three years
before I was like I'm ready to go do it
again and So eventually left to go start
another company but uh yeah it was I
finally found a job I was like I kind of
like like doing this this is cool you
can enjoy a job and how like how old
were you when you started at GB like
what was
the 28 okay so sort of seven years into
the world of work I guess in about
commas you finally found the thing like
oh I actually really enjoy this this is
good fun yeah it was funny because about
three years into investing I had this
thing so some of the best investors are
not people who've ever built companies
so it seems counterintuitive you think
oh the best investors in startups you
would think maybe or at least I did were
successful in investor or successful
Founders they built companies some of
the most successful ones are actually
people who love investing right they're
looking at it as as an investor not as a
Founder but I kind of had this impostor
syndrome where I was like gosh how could
I be trying to help entrepreneurs figure
out what to do in their business when
like I've never built a business that
grew past 10 people and so I think the
thing that ultim and as you invest in
smaller companies I was investing first
in companies with three or four people
and I was like well I've done that I've
been a company of three or four people
and then as I moved to bigger companies
I was like how am I supposed to convince
someone who's running a company with a
thousand people that they want me on
their board they want me to sit at their
you know at the table and advise them on
what to do I was like I can't do that
I've later learned that just a
passionate smart person who is really
invested in your business can bring a
perspective that is really valuable but
at the time I felt like in order for to
earn the right to sit at that table I
needed to go back on the other side okay
a few so I I I definitely want to go
into the follow-up story of um the
company that you then started um two
tangents I want to explore before we get
there uh the first one is that you
mentioned that um when you were at uh
simple Geo a lot of the people that you
still keep in touch with and stuff
you're still are kind of friends to this
day that kind of thing you're I feel
like you're sort of way above average in
terms of people I have on my WhatsApp
who are I feel are good at staying in
touch with people and I always like you
know you've emailed me I think two or
three times in the last in the last few
months just like for for no reason at
all just like very kindly sending me
your like recording of like podcast
growth strategy and I know every time I
get one of those emails I'm just like
wow that's so good like purely like you
you weren't expecting anything in return
you're literally just being super super
helpful and super super nice and it
takes me for six months to reply to the
email and I feel terrible I'm like oh
why am I so bad at keeping in touch with
people why how's how's Chris so good at
it how do you how do you do such a good
job of staying in touch with people I
would say some of the answer comes at
the at the counter to why you know why
am I not focusing more on the things
that are the most important like maybe
I'm so I'm good at staying in touch with
people but I could be spending more time
on you know all the hacks the business
so maybe there's one one element of that
there I wish there was this app this
amazing app a long time ago called EAC
it doesn't exist anymore but what it
would do is it would similar to how a
lot of these banking apps you'll give
them your login they'll go to your bank
they'll log in with on their servers and
they'll download your transactions it
did the same thing for your cell phone
carrier and it would log it would go
download your bill or your usage data of
all the text messages you've sent before
there were WhatsApp and iMessage and all
that and all your phone calls and then
it would also s with your Gmail and it
would take your address book and it
would be like we know based on whether
you texted called emailed or had a
calendar invite with someone when the
last time for every one of your address
people you you know you've communicated
with them so it be like okay you haven't
talked to this person a year and you
could set reminders you could say for
all these people if I haven't talked to
them in a year or for this person every
3 months remind me and then it would
look at all the data and reset the timer
every time you communicated with them I
wish that existed because I would
definitely use that I don't have a
sophisticated system uh I wish I did but
I'm one of those people that when I'm
walking I'm like scrolling through my
phone book all the time that's like my
my habit and I'm just like looking and
if I make it to the D's then the next
time I try to remember that it was I
left on D and the next time I'll just
scroll from d and I'll just find someone
I'll be like oh I haven't talked to that
person in a while I wonder what would be
interesting to send them like say hi how
you doing or maybe there's something
that's one element of it to the point
that I've even created like subgroups of
my address book that are like one of
them is called Walking calls and they're
like people that if I'm going on a walk
I feel like I could just randomly call
them so I'll go to that group um so
that's one is just like using my free
kind of mindless time to try to find
people that I want to stay in touch with
and just forcibly staying in touch the
other is and I think this comes from
content creation as a thing that I've
found later in life I love going deep
and learning things so in the case of
what I sent you I was like I went really
deep and I tried to figure out all of
this stuff about podcast growth and I
realized that I was having the same
conversation with lots of people they're
like oh I'm really interested in podcast
growth could we talk about it and we
talked for 30 minutes and I was like oh
I should probably record that and the
idea came from this guy James bashara
who has a podcast called below the line
and we've been talking about something
and I sent him an email and he was like
Hey I'm really trying this asynchronous
communication thing so could you just
send me a loom and I was like you don't
even want to talk to me and I was like
okay and then I was like wow this is
magical cuz then when we're
communicating this way I can listen to
everything you tell me on 2x so like
life's more efficient and then I was
like oh and if I record something I
could share it with more than one person
and so I thought oh well I gave this
talk at a conference about podcast
growth why don't I just actually record
a version of it that I could just send
to people and it wasn't like published
on YouTube it didn't have but it was
something I could send to people and now
I'm starting to think about oh every
time I Lear learned something
interesting what if I found a way to
share it with people so I do that with
the podcast which I think seems almost
too public if I'm like hey Ellie I found
this I recorded an episode here it is
you'd be like okay well that's like
anyone could go subscribe to the feed I
started doing like the private version
of it and I would encourage lots of
people to try to experiment in this way
um it takes different forms this guy
Nick Gray who wrote this great book
called The two-hour cocktail party oh
okay it's literally like he has
optimized throwing an event to meet and
and build relationships with people to
the nth degree it's fantastic and he has
a he has a friends newsletter where just
puts his friends on this newsletter and
he sends an update maybe once a month
about what's going on his life some cool
links he's found just as a way to keep
people in touch with what he's doing in
life so you can send a friend's
newsletter I love it I get this friend's
newsletter he's like oh I found this
cool thing and every time he goes deep
on something in his life he's like you
know what I want I feel like calendly
which he uses for scheduling could be a
little little more dialed in so he goes
really deep and he's like you know what
here's how I think you should change the
default settings here's what I think you
should put in the thing and then he just
writes a little blog post and then he's
like I'm going to send it to the people
I think might find this interesting so
now every time I come up with something
I think people might find interesting
I'm like who might find this interesting
let's just send it to them I'm not like
hey you have to watch this I'm watching
The Links if you don't click it you know
I'm going to be upset it's just why not
send people things that they might find
interesting uh it helps you stay in
touch so if there's something you've
learned recently if you're listening to
this or an idea or a tip you have don't
feel like you have to go to the extent
of like I'm going to create a blog or
I'm going to record a YouTube video the
video I sent you on podcast growth is
not worthy of YouTube in its kind of
view you know in the quality of the
production right it's like me recording
myself like running through slides in
keynote so I don't feel great about
putting on YouTube and if I wanted to
put that video on YouTube I feel like I
need to go hire an editor like learn all
this stuff and so it's a really big
hurdle for me but to just record and
send it to you I'm like you're not going
to judge me for not having a super high
quality thing if the content's good so I
think for anyone listening that there's
something you you're dialed into or you
learned a lot about maybe try recording
a loom video um or an audio note or you
know writing it out and just send it to
anyone you think might find it
interesting and I think you'd be
surprised at how if you've done a little
bit of research people will find that
valuable especially if you you go to a
place I have friends that every time
they go to a place they create like a
even like a Google doc of like my Paris
recommendations oh that's so handy and
then and then someone's like you hear
someone they're like oh I'm going to
Paris you're like hey let me just send
you this Google doc I have of Paris
stuff and now I have one of London like
you know I think it's just something
that's so easy because you've already
done the research so take the research
you've done on anything in life share
with people you might find interesting
and it makes it really easy to stay in
touch with them yeah that's so good that
is fantastic um okay how do you you
manage your
WhatsApp so it's really easy when you
live in the states I have like three
people on WhatsApp so managing WhatsApp
is like the easiest thing in the world
is it IM message for everyone else yes
okay yeah I don't I have like the group
that we are in on WhatsApp and one
friend that lives in London oh wow okay
so like WhatsApp for me how do you
manage your iMessage yeah yeah so I I
use iMessage on the computer and I'd say
like 90% of the texts I send uh are all
done on the computer it's not the most
organ I I don't have like a system other
than that I hate red dots so like I've
got to respond to it and until they had
mark on red which still leaves you the
Red Dot but like there was just it like
I got to respond so I would say no
system no no fancy way to manage
iMessage other than like but but
basically inbox zero in terms of un RADS
yes yeah yeah I'm not someone who has
like a million unread messages it's like
I I've got to respond okay do you have a
lot of red dots oh God I have I have
sort of hundreds of WhatsApp
unread hundreds of IM messages and
it's it's it's one of those things that
I really I aspire to be the sort of
person that will respond in a timely
fashion when someone messages me and
every time I set that intention for
myself I decide you know what I'm on the
toilet right now I'm here for at least
15 minutes instead of scrolling Twitter
I'm going to scroll my WhatsApp messages
and reply to people but then it's sort
of like email any any any reply I send
generates more it becomes an infinite
kind of infinite Loop or in infinite
well of things that I then feel like
feel like I have to respond to and then
if I don't respond to to it in a timely
fashion I feel like oh it's been like 2
days already it's like it's too late to
respond now I think everyone feels this
way I think everyone feels this way so
if you respond two days later yeah I
don't think that's a problem yeah I
think uh Derek cers who I just thought
of because you have a book of his over
on the wall but I think he's like I
process things like irregularly he's
like I don't even like to respond the
same day even if I am here he's like
I'll wait a couple days so I now I like
kind of respect people to take a few
days to reply to things CU I'm like oh
like this person you know is
prioritizing their time this wasn't that
urgent um so I definitely wouldn't not
reply because it's been a few days
that's and I definitely wouldn't feel
like you owe everyone a reply I I feel
like that's something hard to get over
as someone who has like an audience and
everybody that writes you I feel like
it's really hard I would try to come up
with scalable ways to solve that if you
have a bunch of listeners that send you
questions and you want to answer them
maybe do a listener Q&A episode maybe do
something like that yeah but for just
general friends and stuff I don't know
you just decide is it important if it's
not that's fine if it is I'm sure
there's time I think that like the funny
thing about time management someone I
can't who I think Laura vandercam uses
this example of like look if your water
heater breaks you're going to find a way
to get it fixed because you need hot
water um especially if you're in London
this week you definitely want some hot
water in the shower um but you don't you
didn't have 6 hours that day but like
when you needed to to solve a problem
you found the 6 hours so I think you can
always find the time yeah if it's not
important that's fine like if but if you
if it's hurt if it's making you
frustrated feeling like I don't want to
be the person that everyone's like ah
this person never responds you just have
to prioritize it like you just have to
decide okay let's block an hour for
going through what'sapp and responding
to things yeah I wish there was a
sometimes I like to work offline with
email where I'm like I'll send all these
emails and even if I'm not offline it's
like I'll send them all at 400 p.m. I
use a lot of send later with superum
just so that I don't before I'm done
triaging the inbox I don't have a bunch
of stuff coming back in so that's an
easy one but I don't think it works on
WhatsApp it doesn't work on iMessage
have you tried text.com text.com
text.com oh it's amazing it's like
superhuman but it for all of your
messaging services including imess
including iMessage including WhatsApp
that's been the thing that's allowed me
to most because then it sort of it's
like WhatsApp web but just better and
it's like I message but better and it's
all in the same interface and you can
even do fancy things like have groups
and stuff and I haven't gotten to that
fancy level yet but it's just sort of
superhuman level keyboard shortcuts in
terms of being able to Archive things
and search conversations and so that's
been that's been one thing that's
actually helped me probably two or 3x my
ability to respond to people even though
it's still not quite at the level that I
would like yeah but I think yeah you're
right I just need to prioritize it and
if and currently it's not really a
priority I'm just like whatever yeah and
at the point where it becomes a priority
then maybe I'll I'll start thinking
about it by the way in case you haven't
heard the book that I've been working on
for the last 3 years is now available
for order it is called Feelgood
productivity and it's available on
Amazon and all other major your
retailers and you can check out the
website Feelgood productivity.com for
more information and links to where you
can get yourself a copy um so that was
one tangent on keeping in touch with
people uh I wanted to explore another
tangent which is I'm curious like how do
you think about
money very brly just Brad you know like
just moneyy of money let's go um I think
my Outlook of money has had a a fun
Evolution through my life I think early
on I was like well I just need it to
live and it was like oh now I need as
much as possible so I went down the
financial Independence p path pretty
deep because I was like I need as much
money as possible because I don't find I
haven't found a job I love and I don't
want to work at a job I hate so my
relationship with money there was I need
as much of it as I can save however I
think one theme that has stayed relevant
the entire time was I'm not willing to
sacrifice like the the kind of things
that I enjoy doing so it's like I want
more money so that I don't have to work
a job I don't love but I still want to
travel like it's not that I was
unwilling I was unwilling to give up
those things but not at the expense of
spending the money just at the expense
of finding Creative Solutions like you
can play the points game if you want to
travel for free or you can find
interesting deals or you can go couch
surfing um if you want to live in a nice
place you can go down the world of house
hacking and like get a apartment that
lets you rent out a room and maybe you
can get one that has a separate entrance
so you don't even have to have a
roommate which we did
so I guess I had this process where I
looked at all the way we we spent money
and I was like let's go through each
thing we spend money on and find out is
there actually a way that we could spend
less money on this without having to
give that much up um so I don't know
little things like we wanted we found
out we we we found out when you have
kids you stop eating dinner at 7:30 and
you start eating dinner at 5:30 uh well
we were almost never done with work by
5:15 5:30 so we're like how do we cook
dinner so one option was you end to work
early and then the fancy version was
what if we had a chef like wouldn't that
be nice you just have a chef come to
your house and cook dinner for you and
it's like wonderful so we were like that
would be great but that's really
expensive um so I put an ad out on
Craigslist I was like does anyone that
lives in this General region like
cooking I don't need you to be a fancy
Michelin star Chef I don't need you to
come to my house but could you just cook
basic meals and put them in glass
Tupperware and once or twice a week drop
them off at our house and we found like
20 people said they could we found a few
and then someone would drop it off it
ends up costing about halfway between
like door Dash or you know whatever
other delivery Ser Uber Eats and just
going to the grocery store
yourself but you don't have to do the
cooking and you don't have to do the
grocery shopping and you can kind of
plan the menus in advance so it ends up
having this added health benefit to if
I'm at the grocery store by myself maybe
I'll pick something unhealthy I know for
sure if I'm ordering food I'm picking
something less healthy so it's like you
get a health benefit and a Time benefit
and it's not that much more expensive
now if I had a chef it would have been
way more expensive so I feel like you
know in that window of time I felt like
I had a chef in our house but I didn't
um so I think my Outlook on money
is I don't want
to spend it if I can avoid it but I do
want to have great experiences whether
they're travel or lifestyle or anything
so I think that's like the whole theme
of my life is trying to find ways to you
know upgrade your life your money your
travel everything while spending less
and saving more oh love it is business
class worth it business class yeah and
flying oh flying yeah I mean worth it is
interesting have I paid for business
class I don't if I have it was like one
time on a domestic flight when it was
like oh do you want business class for
an extra $100 have I ever paid $1,000
for business class no or more never have
I crossed an ocean in economy in the
last seven years probably not also uh so
the answer and for people live outside
of the states this is maybe not the most
fun answer but like in the states it's
just so easy if you play the points and
Miles game to accumulate enough miles
and points that you can you know fly
business class for free so I've just
kind of yeah it's totally worth it if
you have a way to do it without spending
a lot of money and the opportunity cost
for me is I could probably go on twice
as many trips in coach as I could in
business because it usually is about two
times as many points to fly in business
as it is in coach so I think it's worth
2X the Arbitrage opportunity is that
when you go buy business class it
usually costs like six to 10x so the
points needs are like 2X and the dollars
needs are you know can be 10x do I think
business class is worth it at 2x yeah
probably um it just unfortunately never
is 2 and and funny enough when you add
in the cost now at least for certain
destinations of like oh I want to pick
my seats and I want to check bags which
you have kids now you're checking bags
now you're like wow it's really getting
close like to 2X
um and because business is often like 2x
the base Fair But it includes the free
check bags it includes you know picking
your seats or maybe you don't care
because all the seats are good so I
don't know it seems like I would say yes
it's worth it but no it's not worth
paying
for have you what about like okay just
some more specific questions on this
stuff um have you found let's say if
you're um staying in a hotel hotels
range from like 10 pound a night to 10
,000 a night what is a good sweet spot
in terms of nightly cost is is has
someone done an analysis on this I'm I'm
kind of slowly doing one myself in my
head but like I'm sure I'm sure this is
a solved problem I mean I think at the
end of the day the challenge is like
okay so what are you optimizing for and
I think there are a lot of ways around
this so one I became a travel agent that
helps on that oh um two uh you can you
there's a great travel Hack That is
probably one of the ones that's been
most valuable to everyone that listens
to my podcast which is book a hotel book
directly with the hotel don't use
booking.com don't use Trip Advisor book
directly with the hotel email the hotel
after you book and if you can't get
their email address call the front desk
say I need an email address for a
general manager you know someone and
just email and say hey I just booked a
night at your hotel or a week at your
hotel I'm coming with these people in my
family or just me I'm really excited if
you're celebrating something great if
you're not that's fine don't mention it
I I I'm not someone who's like always
telling someone it's our honeymoon it's
our honeymoon yeah uh I'm kind of pretty
straight straight and narrow for that
one but and just say hey we're coming
really excited to stay looking forward
to to staying in your hotel and then
three days before checkin follow up and
say hey just want to let you know we're
still coming um really excited for this
day I have seen almost let's say 50% hit
rate on getting upgrade free breakfast
bottle of champagne you know chocolate
covered strawberries one time initials
embroidered on the pill
uh all kinds of stuff from an email
literally just sending an email where
you're not even asking for anything
you're just saying excited to be you're
not you're not asking for anything and
the crazy thing is that this whole
industry still thrives on hospitality
and it's still so deep in the culture of
hotels but when you book through all
these other channels they have no way to
build a relationship with you because
the relationship is owned by booking the
relationship is open by Trip Advisor and
they have to give up such high
commissions to those companies that you
know in general they're like well this
person doesn't care about staying at our
hotel chain this person just cares about
getting the cheapest price and next time
they're going to go stay somewhere else
but when you're like when you take the
time to book with them they're like well
we're you took the time to book directly
with us you must want to build a
relationship we should build a
relationship with you um so that didn't
answer your question at all but it does
increase the likelihood that if you book
something slightly lower in price you'll
get a better
experience um for me it's really like a
balance of where you want to stay
um what you need in that hotel uh trying
to find a deal there there are sometimes
that I won't book direct because I could
find a great deal so if you follow a
hotel on Instagram and you send them a
DM uh they'll respond and they'll give
you a link to go to their website and
book and you can get anywhere from like
20 to 60% off different hotels booking
through them oh W from this interesting
Arbitrage thing where hotels are not
allowed to sell a room at a lower price
than they give to everyone okay so
hotels sometimes pay 10 up to 30%
Commission on sites like booking and
Trip Advisor they would if they sold
that room for 30% Less on their website
they would make the same margin on that
room but they're not allowed to because
the agreements they have with all these
agencies are that they won't price below
what they tell them to the public right
but when you DM Hotel on Instagram and
you get a response from them then they
take you to a site that's not available
to the public and you could argue it is
cuz all you had to do is DM them but it
is not a website anyone could just type
in the URL so they're able to offer you
these crazy deals and so as much as I
love booking direct if I could book a
room for 60% off I'm happy to not have
any chance of getting an upgrade right
like you could probably just book the
upgraded room and still come out ahead
so I don't know I'm Le I I feel better
about getting the best value like I
almost optimize more for making sure
that I'm getting the best deal than that
I'm uh you know spending a certain
amount like at the end of the day if I
want a hotel that has XYZ features and
is this level of clean and Central like
I might just have to spend a certain
amount of money for it I just don't want
to spend any more than the bare minimum
I could possibly spend to get that
quality room y what's the deal with
having an
opir what like what does a noair do and
like to what extent is this a hack for
having kids and stuff yeah so you know
when you if if both people work and you
need to have some kind of child care the
options generally are you send your kids
to dayare until they're old enough to go
to school you get a nanny that comes to
your house and helps the kids during the
day and then leaves you could get an
Alin nanny or you can get an opar which
is someone from another country I think
they have to be between like 18 and 27
and they stay with you for a year and
it's part of at least in the US it's
part of a cultural exchange so the idea
is they're like getting to experience
America um they're part of the family
they stay in the house we you know eat
de meals with them if we go on trip
we'll bring them with us and all those
kinds of things so it's something that
not everyone wants like not everyone
wants someone in your home um but you
know I remember I was listening before I
came over our daughter was going to bed
and our opare was helping her with
bedtime and they were singing songs in
Spanish and my daughter she's from Spain
our opare and so you know it's like this
cultural experience for our daughter
getting to you know experience someone
from another country and learn a new
language we love just like traveling and
getting to meet interesting people so
for us having someone in our home wasn't
that big of a deal but I know that's
probably the biggest deal breaker but
from a cost standpoint if you live in a
high cost of living area even if you pay
above the minimum like they in the
States they're like here's the minimum
stipend you're supposed to pay each week
and I'd say probably 50 70% of people
are paying that even if you go above
that you're still at you know a
significant discount to a nanny who has
to pay for housing in you know the city
you live which can be expensive you has
to commute to where you are and needs a
car and all these other things um so I
don't know I think it's an amazing
thing I think if it were the same cost
we'd probably still do it because it's
an experience we like it just happens to
be a lot less
expensive um I when I was a kid my
parents we had an opair we had four
opars four years in a row all from
Norway and like I remember this one guy
Espen was like who knows how much of
this is true because I was a kid but I
swear he was the best Lego builder in
the world like and I have all these
amazing memories I I was obsess like I
thought my op was the coolest person
ever I brought him to show and tell like
one day for school it was like bring
something cool to show off to your
friends and you know people are like
here's a cool rock or here's my
skateboard and I was like here's this
24y old man um but you know I thought it
was so cool and I like had all these
great memories as a kid of this person
who was living at home and like I got to
you know get to know them and we were
having a good time and I don't know uh
so it was just something that we wanted
to try and the experience for us has
been amazing nice that's pretty cool um
I'll I'll definitely hit you up as one
to have kids to be like right I need I
need more hacks about about the whole
kids thing so here's another great
example yeah please I made a notion page
that's just like you know my baby
planning thing it's like here are all
the things that I thought we wanted to
buy here are some ideas here are some
resources here are my favorite books and
resources like all that stuff and so
anytime I meet someone that's like oh
yeah you know we're having a kid I'm
like great let me just send you this
stock that's Hy like then they're like
oh well thanks for thinking that's so
cool so you know just another example of
like my podcast growth video and this
thing you know this is a great idea so
like um I've I found myself doing this
you do this you have your like gear
guide on your
website like a sort of public for
audience rather than for friends yes but
you have I'm sure there's something in
your own personal life so what one thing
that me and my girlfriend do is regular
relationship reviews and we have like a
notion page where we answer these like
10 questions every couple of weeks and
everyone I've mentioned this to is in a
relationship says oh I'd like some of
that for myself and I'm like okay cool
let me go let screenshot it like air
drop all that kind of stuff I could just
copy and paste it into like a more
public notion page and be like I'll send
you a link and this is a very easy easy
thing to do and it makes them it also
makes people feel like wow like you sent
me this cool thing that like you don't
give everyone yeah um even if you've
given it to hundreds of people like it
still feels yeah I have no idea how many
people you sent the podcast thing to but
I feel so special when you sent it to me
without a BCC or a cc chain or any of
that kind of stuff so good um so see you
probably already have these in your life
and you can start doing them and even
little things like imagine if you took a
list of like the 10 restaurants that you
love in London you s me one to go there
anytime you hear someone's coming to
London you're just like hey here's
here's a few things that I love do you
don't need to provide me with a Six-Day
itinerary uh though for anyone listening
I literally by the time this comes out
we'll have done a entire episode on
London so maybe you know we'll see Ali's
guide my guide we'll see which one's
better um I don't know I feel like the
bar it might be harder for you because
you're so used to creating such great
produced content
and so you're like ah do I really want
to make like a Friends YouTube no no
just make something simple just like a
quick
page yeah it's cuz when you when you
asked me any any restaurant
recommendations I was like huh that's
that's actually a good question and it's
like I've been to lots of good
restaurants and I've kind of saved some
of them on Google Maps but some of them
not like I could just make an ocean page
cuz so many people ask me for restaurant
recommendations when they come to London
it such an easy thing to do yeah or even
if you go to another place like I just
went to London and I'm like w now I have
some recommendations I could
I have a bunch of recommendations for
Japan like people are going to Japan I'm
like here's all the stuff I love um I
think it'd be so easy and then it
creates this cool thing that anytime you
someone's going through something and by
the way when someone's trying to plan a
trip or have a kid or do any of these
moments in their lives they're probably
overwhelmed with information so you're
like hey I've got you like I've got this
thing trying to grow your podcast trying
to you know I don't know I feel like
feel like you're going to have great
relationships in
2023 okay so at this point you've been a
Google Ventures for 3 years going back
to the the backstory and you decided
you're going to start your own thing
yeah what was the story there
so we're talking about money
so I've always been someone that people
are like hey you seem to have money
figured out not not that I had so much
of it it's just like it wasn't a thing
that you know stressed me out like it
does for so many people I I assume this
is a you know a global phenomenon but in
the US money is the number one cause a
stress and the number one cause a
divorce I imagine it's very similar here
and in most Western countries if not all
countries and
so I just was someone who was like very
pragmatic about I was like okay well
here's how it works here's what it does
I go read these books and I think about
it and most people don't like thinking
about money I think that's the
difference it's like if you love
thinking about money it can be really
easy to figure out if you don't you
can't or if you don't then it's harder
and so people were always like oh what
do I do like should what should I start
doing in my 20s or my 30s or like we're
having a kid or we want to buy a house
and I was someone was like oh when I
bought a house uh I was like okay here's
all the mortgage options here's how I
thought about how to buy the house
here's is how I you know house hacked
our way to buy a house that I think was
a way better deal than anyone else could
have found uh if they were trying to
just look for a normal house and you
know that we did this weird thing with
real estate agents and you know we could
go pretty far down just that but we
won't
and I realized that everyone was all
stressed out and there was a process
that many people use called Financial
Planning and they're professional
financial planners they're certified
financial planners there's kind of a
thing they do which is like let's
understand how much you're saving how
much you're spending let's understand
what you're goals are let's understand
how your money is invested what your
risk tolerance is and let's come up with
a plan see if you're on track for what
you want and if you're not let's come up
with plan what you need to do to get on
track like it's it's not actually rocket
science what you do and in many ways
most financial planners and financial
advisers are probably more therapists
than financial professionals but the
process of going through financial
planning is something that almost
everyone I've talked to that's done it
goes in stressed out and comes out
feeling a lot L less stress and more
peace of mind that doesn't mean they
have all the money they need and
everything's already perfect but they're
just less overwhelmed so I was like wow
why doesn't everyone do this like why
doesn't everyone go through financial
planning it's like hm well the average
cost of financial planning was like
2,700 or $2,600 it's like okay well
that's pretty expensive that's a high
price ticket um that's probably a big
barrier turns out there were other
barriers that I didn't know at the time
but I thought okay clearly that's a big
barrier I know a lot of people aren't
willing to spend a few $2,000 why does
it cost so much money and you go talk to
financial planners I interviewed a ton
it's like okay well to get to know you I
have to ask you to bring your financial
statements and email me all these PDFs
and I was like why aren't they building
software that like Aggregates all your
accounts like mint has been doing this
for years there's plat andly or
aggregating tools why is no one doing
this and the short answer is most
financial planning clients because of
the price we're all a much older
generation and they didn't want those
services so the tool tools they were
using weren't really built for this new
generation there wasn't really a thing
there
and so I was like okay what if you just
automated away all the time so if you
looked at how advisers spend their days
half of it is attracting clients not
half but like a good part is attracting
clients because the way they do it is
they take people out to lunch because
that's what you need to do uh you know
when you're charging
$3,000 another way they spend their time
is collecting all this information
processing it put then like manually
entering it into this like old school
financial planning software I was like
what if you just use software to replace
all of that and you use the humans for
the things that are the most important
which is having a conversation with
someone about their goals and helping
them think about the prioritization that
seemed to be the thing that was
necessary so I was like great this is my
great idea we raised money uh I think in
total like $10 million over the course
of a couple years we built a team of 20
people we had almost a dozen financial
planners and it was working at some
scale scale where we had hundreds of
people that were paying customers but
one interesting thing happened which was
we asked people that wanted to like lock
in this the introductory discounted
price to put $100 down and this
ultimately led to us raising a bunch of
venture capital money and we collected
$100 from a lot of
people and then we said hey it's your
turn finally we've hired the advisers
we're ready to on board you do you want
to go and they're like not right now and
we're like oh we're so sorry do you want
your money back and they're like no no
no I don't want my $100 back I just
don't want to do it now you're like hm
okay you paid $100 to like get early
access to this thing now that we're
ready for you don't want it and what we
learned slowly over the course of you
know maybe a year year and a half is
that financial plan is just never a
priority like people have so many
priorities in their mind and in their
lives and with their families that it's
like to stop everything and go through
like a multi- hour process for something
that has very little impact in your day
week month or maybe even year is really
hard people have so much going on you
got to figure out what am I doing this
week what are we making for dinner like
where are we going for Holiday like
there's just so many things happening
that you actually have to solve I have
to file my tax return you know like
there's stuff that's really deadline
Centric and this is something it's like
well this will make us feel better but
practically it'll probably help us more
20 years from now than next week so
people punt on it and punt on it and so
no matter what we charged we just
couldn't get people to sign up at any
fast rate it cost us almost $1,000 to
acquire a customer meaning like we would
spend $10,000 on marketing and social
media advertising all this stuff and we
would get 10 customers but we're only
charging like $600 a year so if you
spend $1,000 to bring someone in who
pays you $600 and of that $600 some of
it goes to pay financial planners the
math doesn't work that was a problem so
we tried a bunch of different
Alternatives and ultimately at the end
of the day
I hope someone solves this I can't I've
probably gotten 20 people who've been
like hey I'm starting a company it looks
like it's just like what you did could
you give me your advice and I'm like can
you acquire customers scalably and
they're like well we're going to build
this awesome product and then we're
going to figure out how to acquire
customers I was like you should probably
figure out how to acquire the customers
first because that's the problem it's
getting people to care about financial
planning enough that they're willing to
do something and spend money and time so
we ultimately decided that we didn't
think it was going to be a good like the
company wasn't going to work we still
had about $4 million in the bank but we
didn't want to just like burn through
four more million of our investors money
if we realized that financial planning
wasn't the answer and what we ultimately
thought was that financial planning had
to be a second product there had to be
something that would get someone in the
door that you could build a relationship
with them that provided immediate value
and once you provide that immediate
value you can kind of earn the right
over time to do financial
planning but we also realized was that
if you could get them in the door with
some product that was good like I'm not
trying to like bait and switch you I'm
just saying if you could offer a core
product that's valuable and you could
learn enough about
people what's more valuable is it
helping them feel better by having
conversations or helping them feel
better by starting to do the right thing
and so I met um Andy rackliff who ran
wealthfront which is a large um you know
Investment Management platform in the
United States and he was like yeah we
have this vision for self-driving money
where we could just build software that
will automate and optimize your entire
Financial life and it's really about
like taking the best of financial
planning and putting it into automation
he's like would you be interested in
bringing your team over and figuring out
how we could build something like this I
was like this seems like this perfect
opportunity and so um we kind of wound
down Grove some of the team came over
and started working on this and I think
it was ahead of its time I think it was
this amazing piece of software that you
could say hey make sure there's
always $7,000 in my checking account and
if there's ever more than
$7,000 I I want you to First fund my
emergency fund until I have six months
of living expenses and once that's hit
then go and make sure you put enough
money in my retirement account and then
go and make sure you put enough like up
to $500 a year or $500 a month into my
kids college fund and then if there's
anything left over just put it in my
investment account yep and you wouldn't
have to think about we called it
autopilot it just would run in the
background you wouldn't have to do
anything I was like wow this is awesome
I think people weren't quite yet ready
to trust a similar to the last I think
they still needed to build a
relationship with you the brand in this
case wealthfront before they were ready
to automate it they weren't going to
come over to do automation but if they
were already there they were willing to
automate so it was a really great
product for wealthfront customers and I
still think it's a really great product
for anyone but I I don't think it's the
the Marquee thing that brings people in
the door um but something like you know
really great investment management or
really you know High interest uh cash
account those kind of things bring
people in the door they get to know you
and then you can automate everything and
so I actually think for some people that
kind of coaching and financial advising
from a human could add a lot of kind of
therapeutic value but I almost would
rather just help people automate
everything and just put the best
practices into place and so that's I
think I went a full 360 or I guess 180
on what I thought you know needed to be
existing in the market and you know now
I love automation I'm like automate my
entire Financial life so I don't have to
think about it move the money to the
right place I don't know that's you said
what do I think about money earlier it's
like I think it should just be automated
and you should just keep it simple nice
so you so after winding down Grove you
moved to wealthfront or how did that
yeah it was kind of like this weird Aqua
highy thing where they were like well
we'll let your team come over here we'll
give everybody jobs your investors
that's the money that was still in the
company could invest in wealth front
wealthfront took over our offices but
like no one got a Payday yeah and we got
stock like you would when you join a
company um so was somewhere in between
like getting a job and getting acquired
but not making any money obviously I had
a salary but um and so yeah I spent you
know three and a half years building
different awesome products in investing
and savings and Banking and Automation
and financial planning and it was
awesome until gosh like a couple weeks
ago decided to go full-time Creator oh
awesome when did the podcast start like
how did how did that come into this
whole journey yeah so
during the pandemic you know I we talked
earlier like I love sharing all these
things and I do all this research pre
pandemic I'd go to dinner and I'd be
like hey guys like I just went on this
crazy vacation and everybody would be
like how did you go on the vacation for
free like we just went on vacation was
super expensive I would like to save
money I would like to go on you know so
much of talking to people that are like
deal Seekers is like oh I know how to go
on the cheap vacation why don't you rent
this really cheap condo uh that's like
10 miles out of town and take the bus in
and you'll save money and then if you
want to go to the beach you can go to
the public beach and you can buy your
own chairs and like you're like well now
I'm not really having a great vacation
and then I would come in and like a guys
I have this great thing and I'll just
tell some crazy story about some awesome
adventure and why how it costs nothing
or how I got a great deal on it people
like yeah so that's what I want to do
like I want to you know I want to live
the upgraded awesome life I just want to
do it at a lower cost and so I was like
H I was kind of missing having those
conversations with people because there
weren't dinners there you know I wasn't
I wasn't a blogger I wasn't you know I
tried writing a couple medium posts and
that never stuck I tried posting about
it on social that just wasn't my
format and so funny enough we were
having a child and I did all this
research I went super deep on planning
for kids and I built this notion page I
was like I'm GNA start a podcast all
about parenting because like I'm deep
down the rabbit hole I'm super
interested so I bought a microphone I
was like I came up with a list of all
these cool guests I wanted to interview
and then we had the child and I was like
wow I don't know if parenting is like my
thing uh as much as optimizing a thing
is my thing and so sure I can have an
episode on parenting but I don't think I
want to have a parenting podcast and so
I realized as I started what I have this
microphone I might as well start
recording something and see what happens
what do I love doing and I was like well
I optimizing travel I love money I love
life I love health I love like
productivity like all these different
parts of my life I like kind of going a
certain amount deep till I figure like
it's dialed in and then instead of
taking that last 10 20% maybe let's find
another thing in my life and go deeper
there and so that became my thing launch
this podcast put out in the world and I
was like oh wow people like this thing
like I guess my idea was put it out do
six episodes and commit to a season one
of six episodes and see what happens and
it just worked and people liked it and
you know I I think I had the fortunate
The Good Fortune of a few people helping
share it on the early days but you can
have all the promotion in the world and
all the marketing success but like if
it's not good people aren't going to
come back and so I think I was fortunate
to have the the kind of amplification
during launch that not everyone has but
lucky that the thing that I decided to
talk about was something people wanted
to come back to
and I think I was like wow if people are
going to come back every week like I
need to produce content every week and
the the one goal I had was I was it's
going to be a weekly show it's going to
come out every Wednesday at 2 a.m.
Pacific and I don't think I've missed a
Wednesday yet I know I haven't missed a
Wednesday yet I have missed 2 a Pacific
technically I hadn't but there was a
button that's like Mark this episode
private and somehow that button got
clicked so the episode went live at 2:
a.m. but no one could find it until
about 4:00 a.m. um but yeah so it became
this thing and it's about 13d travel so
it's not just miles and points but like
you know we talked about some cool
travel hacks it's about one one third
money and then onethird everything else
from you know Health to like I said
planning a cocktail party or anything
wow how did how did you get the
amplification in the early days so I got
this weird email um from a YouTuber or I
guess a internet video maker Nas daily
this year who you've probably met I'm
guessing um and it was this weird email
I I never met him I didn't know who he I
didn't even know who he was and it was
the subject was from television ASAP I
like read this email and i' later have
met him and told him this story and he
was like you have to send me this email
that doesn't sound like something we
would send I was like it was so he sent
me this email he was like he didn't some
person did and they were like oh I want
to make a video about you you have all
these credit card points at the time I
had done this like weird article on CNBC
about having 12 million frequent flyer
miles and uh they're like we're going to
come to your house and make this video y
I was almost convinced that it was a
scam it was poorly written English it
was like nothing about it seemed legit y
and then like an hour later I got a
LinkedIn message and they were like it
was almost the same message and then
like 2 hours later I got a WhatsApp
message I was like wow this person is
really so finally I was like maybe I
should actually read it yeah I was like
maybe this is true like what's the risk
inane yes like if no film crew shows up
then we're not going to make a video so
I said Yes we made this video and so Nas
da made a video about me and that was
like I I when he said or honestly it was
funny because he's in the video but the
entire time making the video we never
met I never communicated with him
anything so I say him but like it wasn't
him yeah he's got a very doed in
operations team and everywhere in the
world and yeah and the only thing I
asked I was like if you're going to make
this video could you at least just
mention the podcast because you know I'm
not getting paid to make this video so I
was like if you're G to make this video
for your content I'd love it if you just
mentioned that I have a podcast so we
made the video and I was like what day
is it coming out they're like this day I
was like that's the day I'm going to
launch a podcast so I launched a podcast
that day um his audience is very
International and my audience now is
very you know kind of US Canada UK
Australia and so I think it helped to
like spread the word so that was part of
the early thing similar to Nick Gray i'
been basically every time I've done
something I've created a newsletter so
when I traveled around the world I had a
newsletter I randomly had this like
annual life updates newsletter and then
when we ran Grove I had like a
newsletter for people we wrote like a
financial newsletter and I was like okay
well all of these things are newsletters
of mine or my companies and they're all
related to me life travel or money so it
seemed reasonable to send an email to
all of them being like hey I have a
podcast about life money and travel
hosted by Me So like um so I sent it to
a news like four different newsletters
I'd built over the last 15 years for
random other purposes and then I don't
know you know you always have like one
or two people in your life that you
could you know ask a favor for but
you're not going to ask a lot of favors
for and I was like well if I'm going to
launch a podcast this seems like the
time to ask for that favor um and so I
just you know said hey I don't ask for a
lot but you think maybe you could help
reshare this thing that I'm launching so
put all that together that created
enough of an initial momentum to put it
out there and then I just kept making
content and asking people if they like
the content to share it and unlike
YouTube podcasts have no inherent growth
mechanism it's like there's no show this
to 100 people and if they like it show
it to 100 more it's just they spread
when people share it but you know it's
been a slow growth path since then but
with growth and you know now it's enough
that it was easy to walk away easy is a
hard word it was reasonably easy to walk
away from a job to do this full-time
because it's now a business um still
feels crazy because it's not like I you
know it's not like I've signed any
sponsor deals that are going to generate
any Revenue Beyond like six months y so
it's a little bit weird but uh you know
it's something that I'm excited to focus
on full-time and gosh only been like 18
months what's it like being a full-time
podcaster like what does your week look
like I spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what I want the show to be
about I think one of the easy things was
if I had done this parenting podcast
there's a easy list every person that's
written a parenting book every person
that's uh you know started a company
that makes things for kids every person
that is a professor about you know
childhood psychology childhood education
it seems like there was just it's so
easy but when you make a podcast that's
about optimizing something it's a very
specific kind of person you'd want to
talk to and often times it's hard to
find the person that has the knowledge
you want and is you know also the right
person to come on a podcast and talk
about it yeah so I'm like okay I want to
do an episode on vacation homes I was
always fascinated like time shares like
are those a good deal you know airbnbs
all this stuff I couldn't find a person
so I was like I'm just going to do this
episode by myself but a lot of it is
like trying to figure out what are the
things that I think are interesting
going deep on it um I think I wrote
seven or 8 thousand words um about
vacation homes for that episode so there
was just like research and you know a
lot of organizing of information uh so
I'd say it's like a lot of just trying
to figure out what the plan is for what
we're going to talk about reading the
book of the person I'm interviewing
trying to come up with staying on top of
all the deals like if I'm going to talk
about all the greatest deals and travel
stuff I need to make sure I'm dialed
into what's happening and so literally I
feel like part of my job is like
scrolling this one Twitter list of
people who promote deals um because I
want to make sure I can deliver and I
don't know trying to figure out what
else to do like I I started a
newsletter that was at at the beginning
I don't know why completely different
but also the same so it's like both
under the brand all the hacks both about
upgrading your life money and travel
yeah but I would write a newsletter
about insurance and I think in my mind
the podcast at the beginning was an
interview podcast yeah and I was like I
don't know who I'm an interview about
all the types of insurance um because I
didn't think like insurance sales people
were the Right audience but if I'm going
to talk about life insurance health
insurance car insurance there's no one
person so it was so natural to write a
newsletter about all of them and it was
so much content that I wrote two
newsletters back to back about all the
kinds of
insurance it never crossed my mind when
I was doing that that I should do a
podcast about it because I didn't have a
person to interview yeah and so I was
writing a newsletter when the same
general theme as a podcast but they were
connected in any way and now I realized
after doing a survey of the audience
that there a lot of people don't like to
listen to podcasts they're probably not
the people listening to us talk right
now though maybe they're on YouTube um
but there are a lot of people who like
the same content but want to read it so
I was like oh well if I'm going to do a
bunch of research or interview someone
to learn a lot about a thing I should
probably take that information and put
it in other places so now I'm spending a
lot of my time thinking about well
there's some people that like to watch 5
minute videos so what would a
conversation with someone talking about
vacation homes look like well maybe it's
here's everything you need to know about
you know Luxury Rentals here's
everything you need to know about time
shares breaking it into a bunch of five
different or five minute segments yeah
so now I spent a lot of time trying to
think about if I'm going to do all this
research on one topic how do I make sure
that all of that information makes it to
all the people that could benefit from
it which means it's got to take
different formats uh and so that's a lot
because I'm not a professional YouTuber
or newsletter writer and like you know
none of the none of what doing is
something I have kind of background in
so yeah that that's pretty cool yeah I
think it'll it'll definitely be
interesting to see how your journey
evolves as a full-time podcaster now
yeah um I guess final thing I wanted to
talk about is you have these principles
for life optimization that I wonder if
we can just kind of go through and just
kind of Riff on a little bit what's uh
what's what's going on there yeah so I
think a lot of people have always asked
me like why are you this way like you
know most people don't you know walk
into a restaurant they're like how do
you get a deal here and to be honest I
don't think there are a lot of deals at
restaurants so I wouldn't worry there
but like in general I'm always like what
what is the way to get a better outcome
here yeah and most people don't do that
so I was trying to figure out why and
and someone had actually told me they
said oh you should write a book and I
was like why should I write a book and
they're like well not Everyone likes to
listen to podcast every week some people
are like I just want the version of
everything you've learned but with a
Finish Line and a newsletter and a
podcast they don't have a Finish Line I
was like what would the book be about
cuz it wouldn't be about something that
changes like it's not going to be about
travel hacks because those change over
time and you know you're not going to
read that book 10 years later some of
the principles of money are there but I
feel like my thing is more about
optimizing lots of things and then I was
connected with this
woman and she was basically referred to
me as someone who is really great at
helping people figure out their unique
perspective on life but actually turn it
into like a thing whether that's a
framework work a set of principles or
something so we worked together for five
sessions and at the end I actually came
out with like what in hindsight seems so
obvious to me but like actual principles
that are I think what allow me to live
this kind of optimized life so oh wow
number one was like conventional wisdom
sucks yeah and and for anyone L these
are not final I won't I won't hit all
nine of them but uh it's something I'm
working on and I think will probably be
the foundation for either a really long
post a series of podcasts a book
something nice but uh yeah one was
conventional wisdom sucks like every
time I'm meeting someone and someone
says oh like this is how we should do it
I'm like is it how we should do it like
why should we assume that because this
thing is how we've always done it it's
what we should be doing maybe there's a
better way to do it you think that we
should in London everyone no one needs
lunch before noon so I asked a few
people and they're like well yeah you
got to change your schedule for your
kids cuz things don't open until noon
it's like well no like if you dig around
there are places that do open at 11: and
there's places that you so so like I
wasn't just going to take anything at
face value it could be quite annoying I
think to be my manager or friend
sometimes CU someone's like oh this is
how we should do it I'm like well is it
really how we should like you know I'm
have to learn to dial that down so that
was one I think questioning the outcome
you want was another big one I've met
people that say you know I need more
money I'm like why do you need more
money they're like well I need more
money so that I can retire a little
earlier why do you want to retire
earlier like well I want to spend more
time with my kids uh right now I feel
like I don't see them that much but if I
could retire earlier yeah they'll be a
little older but I'll get to spend more
time with them it's like oh well if you
want to spend more time with them what
if you could spend it now oh I can't
spend it now because I have this job
it's like well the thing you really want
might be to find a way to work a job
that has more flexibility and maybe you
don't actually care about retiring 5
years early maybe you actually care
about having flexibility now but we
started this whole conversation about
you wanting more money yeah so in
product management there's this thing
called the five yse where a customer
says oh I want this thing and you're
like why and they're like well this and
you're like why and you just keep asking
why until you get to the point like oh
that's what your your unmet need really
is and I think we don't do we we might
do this as product managers doing
research but we don't do it with
ourselves so you're asking why do you
want this thing dig dig dig deeper to
figure out if maybe the thing that you
actually wanted is something completely
different and that allows you to change
your
perspective
sick please keep going this is great
just like this is
this one I encourage anyone listening to
shoot me an email Chris allthe hacks.com
I don't have a catchy name for this one
uh but it's basically structured
information gathering so I need to come
up with a name but let's take daycare or
not daycare activities as an example for
your kids so my wife and I were thinking
gosh we met someone and their kids's our
age and their kid goes to gymnastics
class once a week should our kid go to
gymnastics class and I was like well
before we just decide gymnastics class
what are all of the classes they could
go to like let's go build a notion page
for all this stuff and start to
categorize everything and my initial
Instinct was like let's just start
searching but what I've become really
good at over time is let's think about
what I want to collect when I'm doing
the searching so I made like a simple
table on a oce page that was like okay
if I'm going to go search for all this
stuff let's let's figure out like when
are the classes what's the age range to
the classes how much do they cost you
know like how how frequently do they
happen how what do you have to commit to
like you know trying to think of that so
that I'm not one wasting my time which I
imagine had I not done that I would have
gone and I would have come up with this
list and then my wife and I would have
sat down and be like oh yeah there's
this one class she like oh okay well how
much does it cost oh let me go look it
up and now we're wasting our time
Gathering all this other information or
we're punting and saying well let's talk
about it next week when the goal was to
actually go and decide what the class we
want our daughter to take is and so if
we want to be optimized with our time
and with the outcome let's have a little
more in intentionality with how we
collect information and in many cases
this is just like think of the you know
cells in a table that you want to fill
out in advance but I think by doing that
it changes what you collect and it lets
you process that information a little
more easily or at least a little bit
more efficiently after the fact dude
that's such a good that's so good I've
been for the last year and a half of
living in London I've been thinking
every week I should join a kickboxing
class and I've never won sat down with a
notion table to just think okay let me
actually actually look at these options
because I'm also not sure cake boxing
versus boxing but some some kind of
combat sport but then I look at a
website I'm like I've got to ring them
up like oh I I'll do it next week and
I've been pushing this off next week's
next one for literally for the last 18
months and all it would take is to just
make a table in video let me actually
find out all the kickboxing and boxing
classes in and around my area with like
the time the date the price good not
going make a decision yeah and you could
probably just thinking from the deal
standpoint I bet one of them probably
has like intro offer where they're like
first class free if you found the one
you wanted I bet you could email them
and say hey I'm thinking about joining a
kickboxing gym this other kickboxing gym
offers a first class free I'd really
like to try out your gym I bet they they
give you this they' match that offer
maybe you can go to seven kickboxing
classes for free you just try alleven of
them see which one I like um so good so
yeah so I think the one that's been the
hardest for me is knowing when to stop
and I think it's become something that
I've gotten much better at but at the
beginning was really hard so it's like
now let's go back to a trip that we took
to Greece and we were like oh you know
we're going it was our first trip we
took without children a couple year year
and a half ago we were like we want to
stay at a nice place we narrowed it down
to three places and we had our notion
table and now we're like how do we pick
and I think we probably went too far
where we like o like let's let's try to
imagine what the rooms are laid out like
we went just went down any one of those
hotels would have been fine we've now
gotten to a point where both personally
and with my wife we're able to look at
each other and be like should we keep
going like we have these mental moments
where we're like did we optimize enough
such that we'd have more value figuring
something else in our life to spend time
on than continuing here yeah so I think
learning both practical ways to do that
which is just like literally you could
set a timer like we're going to talk
about where we should stay and 20
minutes in we're going to stop and ask
ourselves do we need to keep going or
can we just pick yeah um a great example
uh Patrick mcginness who was the guy who
coined the term fomo his thing to me was
he's like if it's an un decision and you
wear a watch which I don't but let's
pretend I do uh look at your watch be
like okay if you narrow to two choices
and it's like if the second hand is on
the left do that one if it's on the
right do that one like find whatever the
easy simple way is to make a decision
the less important the decision the
easier it is the higher Stakes the more
you can't leave it up to the second hand
um and if it's kind of in the middle his
thing is just ask someone else like it's
very easy when my mom messages me and
says which printer should I buy somehow
I can give her a response in like 5
minutes like wire cutter what printer
Mom buy this one but if it was me buying
the printer I'm like I would normally be
like cut yeah like you know what what
are the other things the wire cutter
looked at and is there one down there
where they were like we didn't review
this one yet but it looks promising
maybe I should go build my own room you
know it's seems so easy for me to
process stuff for other people and so if
you have someone that's like that uh in
that area of your life maybe just ask
them nice like if you're if you're stuck
so I have a few things like that or ways
to get unstuck to stop going too far
down the optimism Rabbit Hole solid so I
don't know those are a few teases of
these kind of principles for living an
optimized life and people can check out
the podcast to find out when more of
these principles will come subscribe and
I I'll share them as they as they
develop fin a question um productivity
what are your hacks for productivity I
think Outsourcing things you don't love
is like a great one so we already talked
about meals if you don't love cleaning
your house there's an option you don't
love doing your laundry there's an
option you do love doing your laundry
but you spend all weekend doing it try
to fit it in during the week
I feel like there's a lot of times where
if you're working from home especially
if you're not this is a lot harder but
this is like a simple productivity
thing you always want to make sure
you're home for changing the laundry so
it doesn't sit in the you know in the
wet wet wet washing machine forever but
you can just fit that in usually to your
workday so instead of trying to do it on
a Saturday or a Sunday when you're like
okay well I got to be home for three
hours to do laundry maybe you could just
do it in the workday and like slip in in
between a meeting to change the laundry
over so that was that was a good one I
can't remember where I picked that one
up um on the computer I'm a big fan of
Alfred I'm a big fan of uh superhuman
and like any app I've recently I don't
know if this is productivity or not but
I've been playing with a new thing
that's not out yet called rewind rewind
I think it's rewind. a oh and I can't
tell if this is like the most insane
privacy violation in the world or the
best tool I've ever used but I think one
of the the things that saves me a lot of
time so in the bucket of productivity is
not having to document everything y so I
loved how I was talking to Thiago Forte
whose book I also see on your wall uh
and he's like you know you think I'm
building the second brain and I'm
putting everything in it I'm putting
like one or two notes a day in it I'm
not trying to put everything in it and
so one of my challenges is like I spend
a lot of time collecting information and
doing research but I feel like I have to
save it all so what rewind does is
it records everything you do on your
computer it record I'm pretty sure I
think it also records your microphone
like it records everything and if you're
on a website you're in an app it not
only records it but it ocrs it and like
recognizes the text oh H so just for fun
I started using this and I searched T
yesterday yeah and it like pulled up um
the Google spreadsheets page for a you
know a London itinerary where I had like
go to a afternoon tea it pulled up
uh you know a Wikipedia page I was
looking at about something around te it
pulled up all the pages of the sites I
was like wow how many times and maybe
this is just me but have I like tried to
go find this information or tried to
figure out how to save it or tried to
search for it it took me so much time
trying to find this thing so it's
basically like imagine if you could
search through everything you've done on
your computer yeah um and and
conceivably like I believe that it's
also recording audio so it could search
through the audio of what you've said
the websites you visited the things
you've written so I honestly don't think
I've done you know it's kind of like
early beta invite from friends but um I
got to think more about the Privacy side
of it like yeah that sounds pretty cool
I believe it's all local so it's not
it's not getting web processed you're
not like uploading your audio files yeah
I saw this on product hunt a few weeks
months months ago when it came out damn
that sounds sick so I don't know if
that's really I I struggle to decide
whether that's productivity or not but
I'm going to put it there um love it
that's so good amazing right Chris thank
you so much this been absolutely
wonderful it's uh midnight now so I
think it's a good time to end this and
we can definitely do a part two when uh
I come visit the us at some point love
to do that in the New Year all right um
any any final um any any requests any
asks of the audience while while we're
while we're here people who might have
listened to the last 2 hours and 15
minutes of this
podcast okay I'm going to leave you with
two things nice I'm gonna give and then
I'm gonna ask so
first when you're buying anything I love
getting a deal if you haven't gotten
that so far I don't I don't know if
you're shopping online I'll just share
like a fun thing that I do so I'm going
online I'm trying to buy something step
one I always make sure that if there's
some shopping portal like rettin or
anything on cashback monitor that
there's some way to get cash back for
shopping online I'll do that okay I'm
also using whatever site to find promo
codes I find that's really hard it
doesn't always work that much anymore
but the few other things that I'll do do
which are fun I'll search online for
coupons that I could buy so every now
and then you'll find you know in the
states I do it on Craigslist some
classified sites even just sometimes
searching there are people who like find
these coupons and they actually just
sell them but if you're spending $1,000
and you can buy you know a 15% off
coupon that you couldn't get just
searching for promo codes that's one um
I love asking live chat similar to
similar to the style of Airbnb discounts
I'll just be like hey I'm I'm on your
website would love a discount I would
say 50% of the time someone's like
here's a discount 50% they're like nope
we can't offer you a discount one time
someone said I can't offer you a
discount but we do have this great
referral thing that if you can find
anyone that can refer you you'll get a
discount and I just go to search.
twitter.com and I search for like the
name of the product and like use my
discount or something and then I find
someone's referral code and you know
they're going to get a great referral so
that's great for them um and then
another fun version of this so I'm like
always trying to figure out how to get
like the best deal It Feels So Satisfied
even if I just saved like $5 I just feel
really good and it's probably a waste of
time and anti-pr but gosh knowing you
got the best deal out there the last one
is let's say you have a credit card that
earns you some type of bonus on
something whether that's at Amazon or
whether that's at grocery stores or
office supply stores there are so many
places these days that sell gift
cards so if I'm going to go buy
something from Home Depot you know like
a I don't even know what you kind of cat
Home Improvement a home improvement
store uh in the US I'll go and I'll
first search for a coupon I know there's
this website save end deals.com that
sells Home Depot coupons they also sell
like Crate and Barrel coupons and all
that stuff so I'll go buy the coupon
I'll go through the cashback portal but
I don't have a credit card that gives me
four or five points per dollar on Home
Depot so I'll go to the grocery store
I'll go to Amazon where I've got an
Amazon card and I'll just buy Home Depot
gift cards and I'll get the 5% cash back
on Amazon for my Amazon card or I'll get
the four points per dollar at the
grocery store and then I'll buy the
thing I want from Home Depot with a Home
Depot gift card so I'd say like if
you're shopping online there's more than
one way to get a deal so I'll leave you
with that if you're still here and you
like upgrading your life your money your
travel you want more deals you want all
the hacks check out my show you're
listening to podcast it's probably easy
to find just search all the hacks or if
you prefer email I don't know why you're
here listening to a podcast but you can
go to all the hacks.com Chris thank you
so much thanks for having me all right
so that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye